You
You know, you know what I forgot to do? I forgot to actually copy and paste the Fuji Tech model in
I was like, okay, but you will see amazing this and just a moment and just mere moments you will witness the majesty that
That Toma made me into you are not ready tarnished. You are not ready
Hey
Hey, what's up hold on let me put my helmet on for this
I think I need to make it big. Oh God, I don't think this is gonna work. I have I was ready to tape this on my head
Tape it to my boobs, that's a good idea actually
There you go, I'll put one on each tit
But look hold on let me just throw this off to the side real quick look at the amazingness
That Toma did today look
We were just in call hanging out in Chattin
And I'm like I'm like oh my come my my
My model is really lagging while trying to run the game. She's like I got you
And I was like I'm about to draw myself as a like a little like stick figure puppet thing
She's like bet and then she's like no I got you and then I
watched an amazement as she quickly whipped me up into a
perfect muppet version of myself
And it is I am you guys don't understand how happy I am
And yeah, she had a little thing with the pinky out cuz I'm fancy I'm a lady and
The stick was a great touch in my little nails and I just please I have
Tomas twitch and my pinned please give her a follow. She loves doing drawing streams. She loves doodling
She loves watching cartoons. She loves playing games
With her audience. She is one of the most wholesome comfy streamers
I have ever met and I'm so thankful to call her my friend
Because she envisioned me in the most beautiful way my true form
Rise tarnish, so I'm gonna be over here
Let me make myself a little bit smaller so you can see my wonderful little hand holding me up
And a little eyebrows, I'm gonna put this put this helmet on my my booba
We'll do one and then
I'll do how the heck do I duplicate
Let me duplicate copy
Paste
Yeah
Thank you, I feel I feel I just feel so alive
Are we I just feel
Like I'm my true self in this this form
Uh
I I showed off
my Muppet form in the discord and my
Management just responded with just five nights at Friday's music
I'm protected where it counts, you know, I have the highest level of armor, you know, okay, I need to
Set things up a little bit more properly. Hold on. This is gonna be loud for you guys. Let me turn that down
Okay
Oh my glorious day, I am so happy to be alive. I'm so glad to be here
I'm a fucking Muppet ladies and gentlemen
Um, but yes, I am a Muppet because this outlandering really taxes my pc
So I thought it would be a good idea. I was gonna whip up
Um, a PNG batoma came in clutch
Um, we're going I don't know if I'm going to try to speed run
To get to the dlc. I'll be honest with you. I highly doubt that I can do that
So what I'm thinking and this has been a goal of mine
Elden ring is near and dear to my heart
I think I should make Elden ring a running series and this will be the game the the souls like I beat on stream
Maybe I don't know
Honestly, I'm quite embarrassed to
Play this game because I'm not good at souls likes. I enjoy them a lot. I'm not good at them though
um
but
I love this game a lot like that's why I named one of my fucking cats after one of the characters
I was when I was
In such a dark place when this game came out and this game brought me back to the light
I I rose as tarnished. I became the Elden Lord
Actually, I became Lord of the frenzy flame in my ending that I you know beat the game in but it's whatever
um
I've seen the cart bot animations of elderly. I have not helped look that up
I remember pouring over the lore pouring over the builds because I'd never like played a game of scaling before like a all that stuff
And I realized how much I enjoyed it
um
I always like to the guidance of grace. Yes. I always used to like sing to myself
While playing elderly ring reach out and touch grace
Um, yes, I'm a muppet
But
Yeah, we'll try I want to try it would be cool to beat this again. I play
I'm not like scrawny. I don't beat games in like a short amount of time
I take a very long time like she just like a hundred percented assassins created like two days. I I can't
I think when I played and beat the game I had like 200 out. No
Was it 200 hours? I don't know
Because I like to explore
I know there's even so much more that I haven't even found yet and I've been all over the place
I'm debating whether or not to do some like cheesing in terms of like, um
Getting extra runes and shit
Uh, or just like really going for it
Getting all the bells took you 200 out. Oh, you got all the bell. I did not bother with that
What is the shiba model? What do you mean? This is I don't look any different. I'm the same
Sorry, I need this so it's fine if you want to as well. I yeah, because normally, you know, I'd like go to caled
Kill that dragon that's already kind of half dead get the runes level up
Um, but I kind of just want to go on a little trip with you guys, you know
Just want to go on a little trip. I think I want to go on this adventure together
Wait, where did obs go? It just disappeared as I was talking
I'm wondering if I should eat something before I start
Episode of Muppets is this it's the banned one
It's
Fun to pull the cradle
It's on pc. Yes. I have beat uh, so I've never played elden ring on pc. I've only played it on my playstation
um
Maybe wise if you're gonna go for a while, you know, yeah
I was so caught up chatting and having fun watching toma draw my lovely
My true form that I forgot to have a snack. So I'm gonna grab some snackies and a drink
So fun
Reina's doing well everybody
Right reina
She has been snuggling with me all that's fine
You're such a speedy gal
Where's my water?
Uh, I appreciate you guys for
uh
Understanding they'd be canceling and stuff like on us to be honest with you. I hate canceling and postponing things
um
Because like I'm someone who like I have to see things through
Uh, but I was really sick yesterday
Was a bar. I'm still kind of nauseous today. I don't know if I have food poisoning or uh
My medication is like doing something to me or whatever
But I'm okay
In fact, I'm re-drinking some water repeatedly
Do do do do
I'll first always yeah, I was like toma a messenger and I'm like girl
Uh, I might be only able to stream for like an hour because I don't feel good and she's just like no no get no
We could do this another time stop
I'm like, okay. She's so good. She looks out for me
Um, and then I'm kind of happy she told me to just like get some rest and stuff because I literally after
I finished like messaging her. I literally just puked and then I passed out
No, I don't I don't know. I don't know if I got food poisoning again. Um
I'll make some peanut butter toast
It really sucked because I was really looking forward to the stream
And I think uh, some of you guys are like, it's probably stressed. You're probably right. It could be stressed too
Stress can definitely cause an upset stomach. Um, I always worry about rena. She is older
I'm like you every five but the kitties have been good
I'm good now. I've been sleeping. I slept a lot. I rested a lot
drinking a lot pd light
I uh
Was taking everybody's advice when I asked on my and it's my alt account about
What foods you guys like when you're sick?
It was very helpful
I actually almost got some
What is it called
The beef soup the Spanish beef soup ever get something different del res des res ever get
Yeah, and I got ginger ale. She's like, did you have ginger ale and I'm like, yes, I had ginger ale. Thanks mom
Um, yeah, today's been better
Uh, do you still have that puke? How much for it? It was flushed down my toilet
I can I can send you my toilet water
Beef and not chicken. No, I did have chicken soup, but somebody had recommended. Um
Oh my god
Uh, Calda there is
Which is very tasty. I've had it before and I like how hearty it is
I like honestly really want to go to grocery shopping so I can make myself a nice
uh stew
What is this sonic? Oh, oh
Oh my god
This could definitely be interpreted as a sonic. Oh, see. Holy crap
I was your build during the three fingers run. Uh, I was a faith build
um
I scaled with faith and
uh
I was I just really had the halo site the entire time like I farmed
Um that whole part of calid to get all the armor and the halo site in the sphere
um
And then I literally just spammed the fucking
Halo
Uh magic thing
Why do they have to put rabbits in sonic? Why not? Why is twanish?
Hardest boss in your opinion
Uh, the tree sentinel done
I would say tree sentinel just because of like he's the first guy to run into you
But I'm trying to think of who the hardest person I thought was I think
I remember
I was like losing my mind after redawn like I probably spent like so many hours. I think I spent like six hours
fighting redawn
But it was so satisfying when I finally fucking killed him
um
And this is again, it was my allen ring was kind of my true first
Soulslike from soft game that I ever played like I didn't I have I played sakuro. I played dark souls
Uh, I can't remember if it was two or three
I was it two or I can't remember
But like I never played through the game because I didn't know how the game worked in terms of like, yes
It's hard. You're not supposed to just be able to beat things
um like in sakuro and in whatever dark soul games I played
I like was getting so upset because I thought I had to beat the first boss to continue like the first thing you run into
Which is not the case
So I'd say like redawn was hardest because I I had never played the type of game before so it was mentally taxing
um
but
actually
The god skin
Twins were pretty fucking annoying
They were actually really fucking annoying to deal with
I think of it
God I sold her in the beginning as hardest. Yeah
I forgot to tweet. Why don't you tweet for me?
I bought the dlc. Yes, I did
You guys bought me the game and I said if you bought me the game I'd buy the dlc. So I bought it
It's my toaster
I think also
What I haven't been helping myself out is I've been eating a lot of spicy food, which I can't handle that well
But I eat it anyways
And I think my body has just been rejecting me because I haven't been doing that
Everybody's like stop your white jeans cannot handle this much spice
Let's stop to it immediately
Our life will be forfeit
I
I'm buttering my toe. Wait, this has mold on it
Wait, but I ate toast the other day. I just bought this toast
Oh, no, is that why I've been sick because I've been eating fucking moldy bread. Are you fucking kidding me right now?
Well, so much for I literally just bought this bread. Are you fucking kidding me?
How did this get fucking moldy? Holy shit, that's bad
Okay, well
Never mind
So much for that
Uh
Well
Yeah, toast bread is it? No, it's like it was my normal bread like it's normal bread
I just bought it like a couple days ago and I ate some the other night and I'm wondering why
If that's what's made me sick if you guys I made some in the dark with my glasses off
So I definitely didn't see it
Okay
That's why am I such a failure
Yo favorite girl failure miss she be caught in the bomb
Time to order that pizza. I know I'm like
I'm debating
I'm debating whether I have to order something now
I need to go I just need to go grocery shopping. I that's what I need to do on my day off. I need to go grocery shopping
Boomi, what are you doing? I'm trying to steal stuff. Don't look at me like that
Yeah, why are you purring?
Okay, it doesn't matter. I have rice cakes
Holy rice cakes
I can't believe they were so moldy
I feel sorry for that. I'm so I'm so mad
I put some rice cakes
some peanut butter over rice cakes
And then we'll lunch and have a chat
I'm sorry. I can't see chat because I'm like across my kitchen in the other room. What are you doing?
I mean, what's up?
Hello, can you move mister?
Who?
Boomi just likes to be underfoot as cats often are
He is sitting crittily to the side
And then I don't know where we're going. She probably went to the team
But I hope you guys are having a good day today
I'm very excited to play Ellen ring. I love Ellen ring so much
Oh, so so much. I can't because I know that the game is so big. I know there's so much
I don't even know about even though I felt like several hours and hundred hours into it
And I can't wait for you guys to show me things
Um
You so for one thing I will say
You guys don't have the backseat
I played the game if I need help I'll ask for help
Um
But yeah, like and yeah, also when you guys in since you guys like some of you want to play
I don't know how that will work
Like don't we have I don't know if we have to be like friends on steam and stuff and I can't do that
Um
Okay, I got that
I also have some corn bread
Let me get some corn bread
I think I also have like one little chicken noodle soup can so I could have that for dinner
This veal or just of course bread perhaps
That's why I don't buy bread from this or they don't throw at the bread that's used
Maybe I think that's why because I'm like I just bought this decision. I have not gone bad so soon
Madam you have to press new game
Yeah, no duh. Why are you?
Oh, you're being fucking cheeky. I see you
Uses a password system in game. Oh, okay
There's the same pattern. Oh, okay, that's good to know
Wait is my stream like super laggy again like before
Let me see
Why is it that when I did my other stream it automatically
Put it as
High latency and not low latency, but now it's fine make that make sense
Yeah, yeah, it's it's very it's very fun. It's fast. It's good. I'm gonna
Do this that looks fine
barely visible
It's still visible even if I put it at zero so I'll just
Keep it to what it was before
super high
So I can see everything. I'm just about at five to be honest with you because I am fucking blind
Yeah, I literally only got it like three days ago the bread
I
Should be fine
Oh, okay interesting. So last time I was a confessor
So I'm usually someone who does like
One sword and then other hands
Magic
I did I did do kind of a faith arcane bill last time because I used a lot of dragon stuff
And I'm debating whether or not
To
I just think this is funny because it's like the male and the female and the male and the female look exactly the same in the prisoner one
Spell bleed. Yeah, like I usually so I had like the halo scythe
And then I also
Would just use like arcane magic
um
And then I would also because I also had the black knife and I would abuse the fuck out of the black knife
I never even had to use like
I would literally just mimic tear and the mimic tear would distract and I would just spam the black knife
Uh special thing
Summarize the easiest one to start I might do that
Liza p has been t- yeah, yeah
I agree with you. Liza p was really fun. I have to I ended up beating that off stream. So that was good
Mimic is a true lord. Imagine there was a plot twist
And like the mimic goes evil. That'd be a cool DLC crunch. I'm eating my rice cake
I kind of want to scale with magic a little bit better
Right
I might do the profit
Remember for one build I did like dual wielding daggers and that was the stupidest thing ever did
Because I just didn't have good daggers. I can't remember the ones I used
Oh
Thank you, Anonymous for new bread
Come get this bread
I'm like debating whether or not retch
It's so funny
Yeah, I can't even more moldy bread
What up what bill did strani go for
Wanting if I should do the no prisoners more intelligence
again, I
like the confessor because I do feel like it's
Easy and well-rounded, but I kind of want to do something else this run
I might go profit I'm wondering if
I'm like should I do something different because I know faith in the arcade and then profit would be good for that
Because I remember when I first played I just picked anyone. I'm like this looks good
Like I didn't do like a mad like I didn't do an intelligence build. I know I've never done an intelligence build
Although I know you can be absolutely cracked with an intelligent intelligence build
Yeah, you know what I might I might go with a stroller drew them because they still
Like they still are pretty good
A prisoner maybe
Prisoner face okay
I
Honestly, I think I prefer the prisoner
Because they have high intelligence. They have good faith in arcane, but they also are level nine and have yeah
I'm gonna go with I'm gonna go a prisoner
Yeah, magic glimb blade is a good spell. I think I'll do that
Uh B
My titties are out
I'm telling the space fun to go spellcasting. I know I've never done full spellcasting
I've only usually done like with the weapons, but I also but I like smashing things like I like stabbing things
I'm like already trying to think of like. Oh, I know where this weapon is like. Maybe I should go get that one
They also have a sweet hat. I can knock people I can headbutt with people with it
Playing as a gift for my lord video
Um
I'm wondering if I should be a woman or a man
I've made a male build. I did my bandit was a male build, but I'll stay a woman
Age we are mature
Origin prisoner. Oh fucking yo
I'm a little confused by this face and this body type
Uh
Why does it my part of the face is the same? I don't know if I like that
Sorry, let me go back
Keepsake, uh
I'm real last time I did stone sword key
I use that to go to the first grave or whatever fuck it's called
I could get ashes could I go and seed
Apparently gender does matter in speedruns what?
A build did you settle on I'm thinking of uh intelligence faith build
Could I never really play with like the magic?
In Shabiri's whoa
Ron is delicious wait explain to me
Yeah, I got I remember I did the limb grave dungeon without knowing what the fuck I was getting into
Yeah, I might do golden seed
I remember I would literally read Shabiri's whoa as Shabari
I was like, oh, yeah Shabari like why would they call it Shabari or like Shabari's great. I just like pronounce it wrong
I'm up is she be kind of cute you can think toma for that
Mimic grace. Yeah, I never I don't understand mimic grace
Am I pressing the right button? Hello
Okay, I guess I can't get out of this
Okay, well, I'll name myself
Damn it. I'm out of Shibi
I smug be
You're not gracious point to the nearest grace site. Oh
I always just add a little comma a little apostrophe
To my character's names to give a little bit of oomph
Shy by madame shy by
I
Learned that from him
I almost had elden scrolls from elden ring. I mean from elder scrolls with how that could she aim themselves
Katan, but um, exactly
Okay
I look quite cute right now. I'm all cuddly in my robe. I'm wearing my cute little
I'm definitely not dressed to play elden ring was all I'll say
I
Little bra panties moment that matches my robe the muppet says under yeah
if
If you manage
To do anything during this well, I look like well, I'll I look like this. I will be so impressed with you
So impressed with you
Appropriate elden ring attires, I don't know
Okay, I'm madame she be
We're gonna go in I'm mature
Do I get to hear the voice
Ah, wait, let me use my controller for this. What am I doing?
What is going on? Okay, perfect
Let me plug that in
What just happened I do not want to have to play keyboard. Okay. Oh, okay. This is weird. This is very odd
Uh, I don't know why dual sense controllers aren't supported for this
You
Can I do the sample? Okay
Perfect
Um, I'm gonna make it look like me so I will be a white woman temporarily
Or I can make myself brown
Damn, I think it doesn't even matter. I'm not gonna even see myself
I made myself like super gray. I made myself like gray with like yellow eyes my first one
I will be
The whitest of women
That's a man, okay, that one looks the best
Why is my apparent age 75 if I'm a mature woman
I
Perfect 56 facial aesthetic. I would like to be a little bit more feminine. Thank you
This doesn't really look any different but go off this
75 is mature execute all time 56
Yeah, I'm I'm wondering can I make myself even older?
I'm just getting more grays. I look the same and I have some frown lines
I can make myself 250
Anyways, let's go. Can I I'm gonna use my
Perfect
Um, let's see
I'm not gonna do all this shit. I'm kind of tempted to though
Nose ridge
Why do I have such a flat what the fuck is up with my face? What is this?
What is that? I have no nose bridge
I look like my I I fell against something
I want to be pretty
What is up with that
I get rid of the bumps get rid of it get rid of the bump
I can't tell what's happening. I just have a giant ass bump in my fucking nose
Okay, that's fine
What is happening here I look I'm just
Oh, that's how I smell your stinkiness. I want to be a cute girl though. Nobody will really see but it's fine
Oh
No
Why is it oh my god, I just wanted to have a normal nose
I
Bro
I'm just gonna be an ugly bitch. I guess that's what I'm gonna. I'm trying to make it look like she be as much as possible
I can't make it look like myself
Like what the fuck is this?
Okay, that looks a little bit more normal
The mega honker
How is she be streamed? Oh, I watched her. Um
Try to make her character for five hours
I
Do I change the height of my nose? I just want to pick it up and put it a little bit up here. It's like so down
That's fine. That's that is as good as it's gonna get
Oh
Oh, what?
facial balance
Nose size nose to forehead ratio
Wait, I need to what am I looking at?
She's more
Oh, see that's that's a little bit more relaxed face. I like it face protrusion
What does that even mean?
That looks a lot more normal she's you know
Kind of has that hapsburg thing going on, but it is what it is
Small red nose and yellow fur exactly
Oh
God that's terrifying. I don't like this at all. I'm scared
What does this do?
Wrong way
Oh god, no, we want a cute little cute little dainty face horizontal face ratio
This looks kind of weird what it is what it is
About 69 okay, uh, let's do my newest ridge. Wait, I just did that. Did I just do this nostrils
Wait, I need to see what this looks like from the fucking side. I swear to god
I just want a cute little dainty fucking nose and I can't even get that because I'm an ugly ugly old woman actually her nose is
The rest of her face is just ugly
I'm just gonna be a ugly lady. That's fine
That's fine
I
Make a muppet she be no, I don't want to make muppet she be I want to be cute
I like taking time to make my characters look cute
Okay, fast baby. Oh my god use the helmet. Yeah, but I'll
know
I'll know
On the inside
What I look like okay, so
It is what it is
Oh god
Oh god no
Oh
God why is that
Just keep that where it was eye spacing. Oh, I look like the fucking thing from ice age the little sloth
Fid the fluff
Um
Can I change my eye color?
Oh, okay, that's just the face structure
We haven't even gotten to the real shit yet
Let me let me change up my lips
Any I got I got kissable lips
You got more pursed lips
Yeah, yeah, mouth expression. I don't know what the fuck that means
She's I got
My millenia build is ready to help you in your journey mistress. Thank you
Just give me some
I don't like kind of makes my face look fatter. I don't understand that
Lip size
Um, let me do my jaw because I'm looking like I'm getting a little double chin
She looks so ugly from the side. She has a horrible horrible fucking
profile
We hate it here. Um a jaw contour. We she's she's mewing. She she's been mewing since the day she was born
Wait, I can't really tell what difference does that make?
She kind of looks a little
I can't really
Oh
Let's feminize that face, baby. Let's give you that v line that v
Lower jaw
Just break your fucking jaw jaw protrusion large
You have a little bit of under bite ever a week leafy is here chin
A little Andrew Tate moment, um
That looks somewhat normal
She's not that bad. I'm looking pretty target here
Uh
I can't like I really can't get over how
Weird the nose is I don't like I don't know why I can't give her like that like I don't know why this is here
Um, let's just go hair
Hair no god
Uh, let's see
Oh
The braids make more more sense because they're although pony tails
I'll do braids
Give myself the Rachel doles out look
I didn't are these new hairstyles. I don't remember this many hairstyles before I'll do braids
I'm not gonna smash which is the sound
All right, you gotta give me so myself the blonde hair my hair is
Kind of orangey almost I'm not a ginger like emmy though. That would be terrible
Actually, I should do the hair color
This
In my wait, no that won't work
Uh, we don't have any white hairs in this house
Fuck I just have to make myself blonde
Temporary colors
Give myself beautiful white hair
I love me and tomahawk are talking about how we love like the white hair with dark skin
Trope, it's so good. Um, that looks like fucking raggedy in here
Yeah, I'll do a little bit of that am I looking at my mup itself
Tomar toma toma keys right there my girl. Uh
Abundant whoa, that looks kind of badass though
Kind of liking it, but we won't we won't
It's her it's she it's me this looks so fucking ugly. I'm kind of happy
I won't ever be able to see her face. Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ. She is ugly
Oh
Is there
Why can I only be a dude
I should have done the young face
That made myself just older eyebrows we're not going to match hair
We'll make them darker
How does it really matter brow let's change the brow
No brows
Like me a little bit of you know, she plucks she plucks her eyebrows
She just makes her look really sad
My eyebrows are normally really thin as you can see in my model
So I might do a little thin brow
Facial hair, uh, I think I should give myself. Oh god
Never mind. I can't even stand to look at that eyelashes
I can't
I have eyelashes. Am I wearing makeup too? I feel like I am wearing makeup
Eyelashes three. Oh no, we want to lift it we want them lifted
Eyes
My eyes are orange red
Can I do
clouding color
red
I don't know what that means
I should make this darker
That looks about yeah, that looks perfect actually
I don't know what that means. I'll just keep it like that. Um eye position. I can change my eye position
Skin features pores. Why do I have so many pores? No, no, my skin isn't that bad
Skin luster
Oh
You know, I'm an oily bitch, so we'll do that dark circles
Yeah
The mascara is running down my face. Oh god
Cosmetics, ooh
Okay, now we're getting somewhere. Just don't look at her from the side. Just don't just don't look at her from the side
Uh eyeliner you
Goddamn no, uh
Sure, we'll be right where we were
Eyeliner color eye shadow. Why am I wearing eye shadow?
Myself like a rosy
I don't even you can't even fucking tell who nobody can see this past my hair
Cheek color. Can I be a little bit redder?
Subtle
There's a vibrant. Oh, I'm looking at my lips
I was supposed to have lipstick, but I don't
In my model they just yeeted out the window and gave it to a zura instead
Let's do a little bit lighter. Yeah, that's better. I'm so I'm looking so cute
Just don't look from any other angle besides straight on because holy shit
I am a hag
And not the good kind
Yeah, zura has like a little like bottom lip lipstick
Let's hear from the side. It's over like damn. She's hot and then she like turns to the side like
Tattoo mark eye patch tattoo
Oh sick
Look at that awesome cool fucking sigils on my face
It looks kind of sick
I was like I always get confused when I see the script in elven ring and then the script and lord of the rings because they look so similar to elvish
Just on like glancing
This makes my face like dirty looks like I have a unibrow I just wanted freckles
Just give myself a knot. Why do I need a bendy that doesn't make any sense?
Oh
The scar is kind of badass
I kind of like the scar
Oh, that kind of looks kind of sick. I'm not gonna lie to you
I got like fucking clawed across the face when I was a wee rabbit
You know eye patch
What the fuck I can be gojo. I forgot about that
Similar face. Oh, oh
Wait, I don't see stuff from the side
Whichever looks the best from the side give it to me
That looks better
Why do you look you don't look nice head on though?
I feel like I should be called brunhilde brunhilde
Okay
I look so fucking wacky
I like how it's been an hour
I'm still making my character you're in for the long haul, baby. Um
Body hair abundant
I
Don't I can't shave in the wild. No, we're giving ourselves some body here
Yeah, I haven't I have to I don't have to shave my legs with my sword, bro
What does this do
Oh, let's just
I can I make myself thick ums
Yeah
She thick thick
Make myself thick
And then I want to be I want to be snatched
Damn it. I can't be snatched. It's fine
Yeah, what that only widens my chest. I thought it would make me have bigger tits
It didn't
My head small
That looks so fucking wacky
Damn giving myself fucking abs. Hell yeah, look at that. I have a six pack. I'm a 56 year old woman with a six pack
Yeah, I'm a haughty with the body. I'm a haughty with the body
Is it elder radius the character? I know my mom
Uh would make fun of me because so like me and my mom not me and my dad like play destiny a lot
and
you know destiny
Very much like ellen ring. There's a lot of character customization and like getting new armor and stuff
So my mom would just joke and she's like, oh, yeah, it's playing your dress up game
We would play
And I'm just like
Yeah, I want to look cool madame she be
I
Have played warframe. I used to play warframe a lot back in uh
Yeah, I played a lot of counter strike and warframe and overwatch
but
I just remembered something funny. I just remembered wait, hold on
Oh
The lines between
No queen marica the eternal is nowhere. That's my mom
And in the night of the black knives, I love that knife though. It's such a great knife in the game
RIP bro
I wish she would shatter my elder
Oh
Best girl wife wife
Best boy
That's my girl
That's my girl right there
I remember staring at this image of right card for like the longest fucking time and being really confused
A war from which no lord arose
It's her
A war leading to abandonment all the art in this game is so gorgeous
Oh rise now
You're tired
You're dead who yet live
All soundtracks all the call of long-lost grace speaks to us all
She's millennia blade of nick micola
For a loom
chieftain of the badlands
Oh fucking
We never brilliant gold mask
That's my cat that's my cat right there
That's all you guys that's all you guys
And circadian up here
They all know it
They all
knowing
I remember there's a bit that game grumps did that really cracked me up when they were doing this first title scene
The all knowing the all
growing
Hi charlie. Thank you for the super gb w teff by looking at elden ring
Oh grace would again bless
My nails are fabulous tarnished of no renown
Hey
The alt working i would love to voice in a game like this
And become the elden lord
My now i've just decided one of my dreams is being able to be a voice a minor character or any from soft game
I offer you in accord
I thought there was a blood stain below me and I was quite confused
Oh my god, why is it showing my
It's showing my keyboard uh things instead of
Let me unplug it and plug it back in my controller
Nope, it's it still wants to do that. Okay. Well, we'll figure it out. That's not it. That's not it
That's not it
Figured it out
It's triangle
You such a controller in settings. Oh wait today
It's showing controller
I wish I could wait
How do I just make it be controller?
Third from right in display what third from right
Oh
Haha, why is it called a game pad?
Oh yippie
What I missed when I was playing lies of pee is that I can fucking jump
Couldn't jump before you can't jump in lies of pee. It's a fucking travesty
Am I supposed I'm not gonna read these I don't really care right now
Is a pad you game on I don't know what type of period you've been having but nah
Um
Kind of wish there was a blood stain there because I remember the first time I played I walked off
Uh, I feel so good to be playing this game again. I'm not gonna lie to you
How do I run? There you go again. I have to remember how to fucking play
Okay, yeah, this doesn't have as much this has minuscule input lag compared to um
Watch him I call it
Sorry, I have to remember how to play give me a second
And then if I press rb that'll be that
And then
Yeah, that's fine. That's cool
Grab game
I like my new drip. Yeah
Like what do you mean me steal shit from berserk? I don't steal shit from berserk. It's heavily inspired
Because
I don't know doesn't the
Wasn't the guy who
Makes this game like a huge fan and then like let's be besties with the guy. It wasn't I don't know
I'm making shit up. Don't don't quote me on that
I forgot how to block
Hold on
No
Hello
Did I die I didn't even notice
Mike was asked he did say a lot of times he likes berserker interviews exactly
I didn't even notice that I died the scream got me. Oh, what's the scream you're right?
My zaki
I died of being yelled at damn it
That's me
That do be me IRL
Yell at me I will cry
Can I skip this? I don't really
Thank you for the
Actually, no, I should have saved that I should have listened to the cut screen
Jump down the hole ahead you will find the cave of knowledge
There you can learn about game controls with basic actions
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Hey
Take the plunge of learning and remembrance recall the arts of war and your warriors blood
All right, I'm gonna do a little explore because I can't remember if there's shit over here
I also can't see
I can't see at all
I may have to turn up the brightness because I I can't see
And I know actually no I loop back around for these things. I don't know why I'm trying
Hey, do be do be do be do
Me instinctively going towards this thinking there's a golden seed
Stop flaming you preps
The don't skip the tutorial on screen tutorial
Skipped over milit I know I know I skipped over her
Oh, hey neat
Hello
Hello, Mr. Obama
I forgot that I can just skip that that's actually nice because I don't feel like doing it
Use tarnish for the right golden summer sign. I don't know. How do I like um
Um
Anyway set a password so you guys can join because that'd be pretty sick. Yeah, I remember this is where I like opened up that
You all grace I am grace reach out and touch grace
Uh lasts I'm gonna
Oh
Menu multiplayer play solo
It's multiplayer settings. Okay, I'll remember that
Let's do it shall we
I'm quite nervous
No, shut up. Fuck off, bro
Do I actually have to appraise you this is poor
I
Didn't mean to do that. Why isn't it letting me switch between
I'm gonna oh
Again, I haven't played this game in a year
If not long when this game come out, I don't fucking know
It's not great. I'm about to be called made in less can't fucking wait for this
look how
Fucking gorgeous this game is. Oh my god, and I don't even have a good pc and it still looks okay
Oh, I love this game so much
Hey
I'm heartless
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, let me just talk to this dude. Oh, yes
Tarnished are we come to the lands between for the Elden Ring?
I wish I could see out of my other eye. No shame in it
Unfortunately for you, however
You are made in less
without
The strength of runes and without an invitation to the round table hold
You are fated
It seems
to die in obscurity
My mom is getting angry because she texted me and she didn't
She texted me some flowers
And she's mad that I didn't respond and I'm like I'm streaming
Okay, let's take it. Let's pop a squat
Every urd has its tree
I know there's a lot of maidens. I have so many maidens. I have so many harlots and maidens
I don't know what he's talking about
to be honest with you
Yeah, okay
All right, so I'm thinking about what to do. I'm not gonna go for the tree sun and all I'm not a fucking
Whatever, um
I might
Be lined I forgot to pick shit up
Oh, there we go
I might be line for the church talk to the dude
Oh, yeah, let's do that
Because I don't I don't have torrent yet
We are now the maidens. Yes, you're forever maidens
Wait, hold on. I don't think I
I don't say I didn't say thank you. Thank you for that super
Leon
Leon James Demetrius you sound like one of the
character names in that one skit that he imputed of the
The university of whatever the fucking football player one
Church of Ella
So a part of me
Wants to skedaddle to kaolin
To uh get to that part or I can stab that fucking dragon to death
Actually, I'll take too long though. You're not after my then why not I am carly
What do you got? What do you got?
Telescope dagger cracked pot
I
Can't I don't have any money
Can I have some
Do you have anything for free? I realize when I move my head like the metal on my neck is like very malleable
What's up with that?
I forget what I have to fucking do for Ronnie to show up
I know I have to it's like a cult I have to go to
I got to go to limb gray. I got it
Wait, how do I pull up the map?
I got a fuck. I don't have anything on the map. I'll just keep going straight for now
Um, I have to go rest at the great to talk to
Um
What's her name they all have an m and their fucking name. Hey turtle
What do you guys gotta say could this be a dog? I'll say that's pretty good
Don't you dare
I
Melatonin millennia millennial
Milena Milena, that's what it is. I always get Milena and millennia Milena
Fucking confused because fuck George RR Martin for naming everything after him indiscriminately
Uh
I need to go
Upstreet
Oh, uh, hello there. Uh, hello there
Anyways carry on
Carry on indeed
Oh hi Raina I'm gonna hang out with me
What the fuck was that?
What was that?
Oh
I just scared the shit out of me. I didn't even hear her come into the call because I'm sitting in
I'm sitting in um
Watch i'ma call it
Art the discord to do the fuji tech and that was Azura. She's all nice and muted. Azura. Do you want to say hi?
Okay
Hello
You're such a goober you gave me you scared the shit out of me
My chat says hello
Hi
All right well Azura is here in spirit, but I will continue
Okay
Hi mom hi, is this your first time playing it is not
By the way, I hear a beetle
You don't see me
Beetle are you up there? Oh wait fucking right here
Ah no
I can't remember how to run
I don't even know why I got this when I didn't have to use one. Hey
Ow
I'm very high stamina. That's pretty cool. Uh, okay, so I have to go
I have to go rest at this grace to talk to malena
Malady malena
I remember I was in here trying to clear this for the longest time
when I'm like
It takes a while for you to learn that in from soft games you don't have to
To kill everything
Run hold dodge what?
No, I know how to play I just forgot I've been doing it before you guys saw me dodging and rolling earlier
Reach out and touch grace
And then I gotta sit and rest and talk to lady
I'm using controller. I swear to god. I'm literally gonna put up a disclaimer says if you backseat. I'm fucking to bop your ass
I will ask for help when I need it
She is greetings
Traveller traveller from beyond the fog from beyond the fog. I am melena. I am melena
So, uh, I didn't say you could sit
Oh god, she's hot
What happened to your eye
Offer you an accord. She just pulls up a Honda Civic. I mean a Honda Accord
I
Offer you in a call. Have you heard of the finger maidens? I finger some maidens. That's for sure
They serve the two fingers. I prefer three offering guidance
and aid
to the tarnish
That's cool
But you I am afraid
I
Uh, I got a maiden right here. I'm me. I'm a maiden
Do you want me to take your maiden hood? I can
I suppose if you insist
Uh, yes, the fabled cock ring
Okay, tuck you in my little pocket of the earth tree sounds suspicious
Oh, yeah, because if you don't
Why can't I I'm pressing accept
Oh the fuck
I remember the first time I think I said no and I had to start my game over
You talk very slowly
Oh my own clock cockering on my own. I don't have a clock though. I'll put it around my strap
It's for a horse. I I'm not into that but I suppose
Thank you very much
Why do they name torrent has chosen you chosen me
I was never a horse girl, but they're nice
Your ambitions it's kind of weird that you say like that
Hold on hold on hold on come back here. Oh, fuck you
Oh my god, okay
Uh
I forget what I was gonna do. Oh
I should just said turned off tutorials, but I know I shouldn't be doing that because I'm going to forget shit
I
Wait what?
Builder you're going for I'm thinking an intelligence faith build. I never really did any um
Intelligence before I did a faith arcane build before
I'm just laughing at my parents because my mom is mad that nobody responded to how pretty her flowers are
My dad's like, I'm sorry. Just call me. You can talk about
Okay, uh, let me pop a squat
I still have enough fucking all right
Are you broth
You get off here actually
Let me steal some stuff real quick like
How do I jump?
Oh, it's not in here. Where is the chest? Is it the other one?
It's the other one in it. I fucking knew it
Uh
There's that many notices bats over there. They're kind of kind of looking at you in the face
Yeah, oh, I'm gonna lock on this. No, I'm locked. I'm I'm gonna kill this
Skull, yeah
Wait, and I probably don't need to kill them, but I want what's in there. I forget what's in there, but I want it
Erm
What the sigma
Hey, you're probably gonna see me kill your friend, but it's fine
Right in the back side in it. Where's the fucking heavy up
Oh a flail I can sell that
I forget is there
Can someone tell me if there's a
Thing below I can't remember if there's like a little dungeon thing below there is isn't there like over there
I don't remember
Let me let me level up first
Yes, there is okay, that's what I thought
What the hell what skull is on my booty?
What is this? Oh, there's fucking blood stains everywhere
Because bitches don't know how to play the game. Oh, where's the grace? Oh
It's a useful chest
Let's see I'm gonna start working on getting my vigor up
Yeah
Just because I need all the health that I can get because I'm not good at the game
Or stairs you go down. Okay
Let me take a peak seapoo
And you made it remember there are dogs have to be careful for the dogs
I can't tell if that guy heard me or just having a tough day
Oh, uh fancy seeing you here
Oh, I need to I can't parry
Here, why don't you attack him? Oh, not me. I said him
I said him go go get him get the guy not me
What the fuck you're throwing shit at me
Anyways, um, I'm just gonna ignore your bad behavior
I'm just gonna look for this. Oh, let me fucking
I miss that's fine though
I'm just gonna kill you I can because you're already weak. Where the fuck is this thing?
Don't you dare blow that damn horn. I'll fucking end your life
Can you stop stop
Ow
I pressed the wrong button. I'm being killed by bats. I died to bats. I don't remember bats being there
My first death I should have a death counter
Do-do-do-do-do
Should have done a no death run just kidding. I'm not that good. All right
Um
Don't look at me like that
Oh, mind me. I'm just looking for shit to steal
Don't worry about it
I distinctly remember it being on the right side
Was it not?
Oh, uh, nobody heard that
You didn't hear anything
Okay, it is that's what I thought
Sorry, I'm maneuvering the camera around to see
Don't worry about it, bro. Um, then I gotta
I'm just gonna peek
Okay, at least the bats are gone. I'm just gonna take a wide angle just so he doesn't get aggro'd by me
Oh
There's the puppy
Is there a guy in here? No
What is the point of this?
I thought I could peek
Hey there, don't worry about it
It's by okay, it's by the guards and dogs. Okay, so
It is right over here
Uh, hey, yo
Uh
Oh, that I'm not making noises. Why don't you come over here big fella?
Why don't you come over here and stay a while? Oh, fuck. I thought I could jump on that not through it
Are you gonna
Ow, ow, why did that miss?
Oh god damn
Oh, I didn't press the right thing
Uh, how do I
How do I use that?
I don't know how to use it. How the fuck do I use my flasks? How do I play again?
Square oh should leave me. All right
Come back here. I'm ready to fuck you up now
Uh
Is it over there? Yes, it is
I'm going forward we're running we're running. I'm going forward. I'm going forward. I'm gunning it. I'm gunning it
That's not it's not over here. Oh shit. Well
Ah
Y'all like this puppy. Oh right here. Uh, we
Uh-huh. You can't come down here, bitch. Can you? No, you can't
A lot of these
Oh
Thank you kindly for the knife. Is there anything else in here? No. All right, let's skedaddle
Irene no, are you looking at me like that? Want a pet?
What are you gonna say? Tries her chest ahead. I would have never a thunk. Um
Well, this is awkward
Not the doggie. Yeah de agro de agro puppy go on
Yeah, get fucked. Um, okay. Wait, I'm supposed to where is the map?
Map thingy. Oh fuck
Oh, it's right over there. Oh, I'm gonna go touch this grace over here first
A noif in it
Let me pop a squat reach out and touch grace
He's a bad boy. Did you equip torrent yet? No, I did not
I
Wow, it's crazy how I how much I've forgotten to play. No, that's the pouch. I don't need that
Oh
I didn't
Hey torrent a little horse goat
I thought in the dlc they're gonna add more seeds and I was kind of hoping because that'd be fun to run around another
Shit like a giant ass wolf or whatever
I
Why can't I I can just discard him
Why
Do we get relearning so far I can't remember how to fucking equip torrent
I
What the hell
Oh wait, I remember I remember I remember I put
no
I put him in the first
Thing of my pouch
Equipment
Torn actually equips you wait what?
Yeah, well that's better
Raina, what are you doing? Raina you want a fishy?
Okay, what to do next? Oh, yeah, that's what I'm gonna unlock the map
I'm eating goldfish
Fell in my titty
Oh, yeah, I should probably go see Ronnie. Let me get the map and then I'll do that
What do you mean, what are you looking at? It's me
These goldfish are really tasty learn to summon wolves I will
I'm too busy dropping goldfish all over myself. Okay
Hey, I'm trying to do shit. Can you can you not I'm trying to thank you
I don't have the time
Ow, I didn't think you'd actually hit me but it's fine
Damn you throwing fucking wheels at me dude
Anyways
This guy actually will follow me far. I believe I don't know you're a diagra
Zoom out
Oh
Hiya boys
Bitch what do you got bolt sick
I'm moving up in life all rise he tarnished
How do I dismount and that's not what I meant to do looks fine
Get me off of this thing
Ready from the tree set and all yeah, this is my 2.0 everybody
Oh
I'm clicking to talk to her what is happening
I must be doing
Oh, there it goes
The golden aura is the grace of the earth
This light once shone in the eyes of your tarnished brethren
It is all that guides you
Also, I hear so you hear you can see them can't you the rays of grace
That guide you through your burden
Is that it
Is a shard bearer a demigod who inherited a fragment of the shadow is there now
If the rays of grace signal the dangerously furry in the elder ring
I'm just a muppet as an ally by pack
I pray that you are fit to face the challenge presented by the ring
The clock ring to rule though, I don't think I have enough room to level up shall I turn your room
Yeah, I will see no, I don't
I don't like that we're awkwardly holding hands like this. It's kind of cringy
What isn't it nighttime
Oh my god, you have to wait a little bit longer
Do muppets count as personas I have a question
I
Know I just fast-forwarded time she's taken too long to show up
I'll talk to him
Just a chat
I didn't mean to jump hey wait
Weren't you well you're back
Care to buy some weren't I dead is that what you're gonna say?
Oh
I'm pretty good. Uh, tell me about yourself. I'm waiting for my girlfriend to show up. So
Yeah, people are dying but not dying it's crazy
Recommendation
Who's Ronnie only Ronnie here Roni
I do take my cut
But the important thing is that you survive
Every custom accounts
after all
Yeah
How much is a copy kit?
Goodbye for now
I'll only be like five seconds. Hold on I say five seconds. I mean more than five seconds
Hold on give me a moment. Give me a moment. Just a moment. Give me a moment. Give me a moment
Macaroni
Easy
What is it stop wasting my time
No, I didn't mean to sell
I will sell this though
I'm glad you took my warning to heart. I'm sorry my sword's just in your face
Hey
Yay
Right now best girl fire keeper forum ghost doll. Where is she?
One day my princess will come. Whoa, I didn't know I could jump up this high
Um
Raina is singing the song over people in the bathroom
Raina
Oh
There's a complete karya manner to talk to Ronnie
Oh, I needed to get one more grace. That's right. I can't remember. I thought it was like three, but I guess it's four
Hmm
There's one like over here and I think there's like one over here
Raina Raina Raina
Raina, what did you catch you guys hear her yelling?
Oh
Oh my god, Raina
See the dragon Raina
Raina mamas, what's up?
Is that pock what the fuck his name is
You yeah you there stop pretending you can't you're a fucking bush and I can't remember which one you are
I can't remember do I have to like hit a bush? Why won't anyone look me in the eye?
Because you're a bush ugly. Am I you're a bush? Which one are you?
Raina, can you please lower your voice?
Which
Why'd you disappear further back the red one slightly discolored sorry maybe to jump
That is
Slightly red discolored bush you
Do
Guys which bush I know he's in a bush. What fucking bush is it?
You
You yeah you there that one stop pretending you can't see me
Isn't it like right over here? Is it this one?
I
Know he's closer to the road
You're lying
You yeah you there stop pretending you can't see me well I fucking can
I thought it was this bush
He sounds like he's right here
It's the random bush with no others around it
I thought it was this one
I
Don't draw these bushes the bush that's shaking
Why won't anyone look me in the eye? I don't see a bush that's shaking
That one
Is that just the wind
I'm gonna stand right here is a tree out
Behind now could you help us out cully
Oh
You yeah you there stop pretending you can't see me
What you going to do that for
Oh, yes, I remember
Some claw turned me into a tree
You were just breaking the spell weren't you? Yeah
The name's bok bok I was pushed out of the cave
Told not to come back not ever goblin with a nice accent a tree
Lucky you came along really
Or bok
Oh
What a shame what when they threw me out of the cave you've they took everything I owned
And so this is all I have to express my thanks
I hope you can forgive me. Yeah, you didn't have to give me anything dude. Oh a mushroom. Thanks
If you can afford to wait for a while
I could sneak back into the cave and bring back something of actual value
Then I'd be of some real use to you. I reckon
He's like I just realized how scary his jaw is
They're like a literally fucking on hinges
Right
I'll need a moment
I'm mushroom dance
So I have to gather myself. Bye. Bye. Have a good work. Have a good work. You know what I mean
Just thinking about that god awful cave on the shore with goblins
Is there anything else okay, that's fine. Bye
Torrent to me ghost to me
Uh, I could have sworn
There was another grace near here somewhere. I know
Dragons over there
Knight riders not out quite yet
Oh
Oh, wait, no, he's right there. Fuck off, bro
No, I was hoping you wouldn't hit me
Not the knights Calvary on the fucking trolls. Hey, why don't you oh shit? Uh, hey trolls. You want to fight these guys?
Yeah
Damn it. I was hoping they fight the night
All right, I forgot he liked fucking teleports back
Okay, there's a grace around here somewhere I believe
It's
We got the dots on like the side of this place
Where is that one like swordsman dude
Hey, what's up? What are you guys doing? Are you just mining sick? I love that for you
Very child and touch grace
I
Hey, I'm just gonna yoink this thank you
Isn't it I could have sworn it's on the side of the road
Is there a walk in
Oh no, uh boomies on my desk. I can't see big boy get out to the way
I'm looking for the little like grace lines, but
A little more down the road and off the side. Okay. Um, I kind of want to go over here for a second just because
Oh
Fucking oh, I just got a shiver. I love this game
I'm taking the scenic route
Clock clock step pick up
Uh boomie, uh, I'm gonna have to ask you to move mister because your tail is in my face
Hi
What do you want, dude
Booby, what do you want?
You just wanted sanction
You just want my korean snacks that are behind me, don't you? Well, you can't have any sir
Why aren't you so sweet? Oh
You please don't boomie oh my god
Oh
You can't hop into this box. There's stuff in it. You would fall. Look, I'll let you look inside
I wish I could just show you guys what is happening right now
I forgot I need to start putting on cat cam so you guys can see
As usually I'll have like a cat cam in the corner
Booby is trying to crawl into the box of my korean snacks
And he almost knocked it over so he would have fallen
There's nothing in here that you want bro
Booby why are you trying to get in this box? You can't fit inside of it
You just want the box is that what you want? I'll give you just the box
I'm a big man. Okay, fine. I'll give you the box. Let me pour these out
Here this box is yours enjoy
You're gonna hop in it
You're gonna get in the box
Boy
Let me take a picture so you guys can see
Oh big man the box
Come here look at me booby
Handsome
I'm just gonna chew on the box
I'll record you chewing on the box for everybody so everybody can see
How crazy you are
Chewing on this box
Why are you doing this?
Okay
Need cat emotes. Oh, there you go. You gotta count the box you wrote
The box on the desk so booby can have his pets
You know booby isn't really like a snugly cat. He'll like hang out with you for only like the littlest bit of time
He likes headpats and chin scratches other if he gets um
It's almost like he's like fucking like ocd or something because if you pet his body he like licks it immediately afterwards
Now fia is coming to take a peek she's sniffing booby in the box you guys are so cute
Booby is still chewing on said box. Okay
Ronnie my beloved I am coming for you soon. Oh, sorry. Don't mind me. I'm just
Doing shit
I
Wonder why everybody just wants to like it just attacks you, you know, everybody just attacks you
Oh, there he is. Okay, so it's around here somewhere
Excuse me, sir. Do you know the directions to the grace? No
I thought you knew what know the directions to the grace. I'm just asking for directions, please
It's around here somewhere
Who is that?
Yeah, oh fucking rune fragments and never do anything with these
I swear it's like on the side of a hill
Sorry, I was like up here
Does that make me crazy?
Does that make me crazy? There it is
Does that make me crazy? Oh shit. Oh
Say a little crazy that nose powder is making its rounds in the land between
Oh, what's up B? What do you want?
Me I'm searching oh for my purpose. Why did you answer my question?
I
Inside
Are you speaking poems and I'm not a fan
You fingered a maiden yet can offer no guidance you're useless to me
I'm no maiden my purpose
Was long ago lost I don't like your long pauses. Then why are you here?
Ew this little thing I just tasted it's not taste good. What? Why does it taste like no polish?
I
Korean snacks really like their little crackers like butter
Pretty good crackers
Listen, I've only had rice cakes and goldfish today leave me alone
My share them with me. I don't have it up. Hold on. Let me check
This gal doesn't hang around much which sucks to how long the road is. I think she's flirting with you. Oh
Theo, what are you doing to the back of my chair?
Was it your turn to be annoying now let go are you stuck?
Yeah, you know you don't have to drag yourself up right you could just like walk
Fia, are you stuck? You feel like you're stuck to my chair
You are stuck to my chair. Oh my god. Hold on
Hi, lady look very cute. Let me help you get off
Oh, you fucked your paw bad in there. How am I supposed to hold you to this?
Are you meowing? I'm going to help you. You did this to yourself, boomi helper
Yeah, I tell you don't use your claws when trying to jump up on my lap and then you're here
Up to my chair
You're looking at boomi like help me, but he can't do anything. He has a half-hands or valued so he should let me help you
Oh
No, her cat claw. It's her claw. She like so my chair
She like sometimes Fia's weird. She doesn't just like jump on my lap. She has to haul herself up
to get to my lap
And um
She'll pull herself up and then she'll dig her claws into my cushiony chair
And there's also like so she's stuck on it
And she's trying to maneuver around right now and get out and I'm trying to help her but she's whining about it
Okay, are you ready? This is a team effort
You don't move your paw
You did it. Yay. Good job Fia
Can I have a hug?
Yeah, it's huggie time
My little girl. That's my little girl getting stuck on stone. Yeah
Fia's gonna keep meowing if you don't feed her
She's fine
Her food already went off today
Yeah, went off three hours ago. She just ate and then it'll go off in another couple hours
They are so spoiled they have an automatic feeder and they have a problem
And they have so many toys and so many cat trees
People come in my mom came over and she's like, yeah, this definitely looks like cats live here
I'm like it's a little cat haven if I could I'd build them that thing where you kind of like
Have them
um
Walk across your walls and stuff like little shelves
I check it on me since she knew I was sick
It's the treats they get lots of treats
Hmm
Let me just focus on oh fuck
Let me focus on just talking to Ronnie first before I try to go kill people for for rooms
Wait
I
So used to play as a pee where you have to go to the
site in order to transfer
Yeah, what's up with your little hot doll body
Mother I mean mother. I mean mother. I am sorry
I don't
I like how she sounds Jamaican
She's like a British Jamaican accent
I heard about the tarnished that
She sounds like I don't know why but Ronnie reminds me of
Uh, Calypso from uh Pirates of the Caribbean. I don't know why she's Welsh. Oh
Oh
I
No way
Okay, the spirits will obey thine command but whatever you say, honey, um
Let me just
I
That's cool. I'm just gonna try to I can't pick up your skirt. Do you have how many legs you got under there?
You got oh, that's me
Oh, wait, hold on. Hold on somebody put a thing in you. So that's kind of annoying and it wasn't my thing
Don't worry about it. Hold on. I like your shoes. They're very they're a choice. Their hat's quite cute. Um
Yeah
Actually, we will you'll become my wife
Do you ever use your hands to hold up your boobs as a bra? Oh, bye
I'm staring at her hands. Fuck fucked it up. Fucked it up. Stupid stupid stupid
Oh
That's a vision of Trump
I think they had the same idea as me trying to look up her skirt. All right
Here's the plan
I don't have one
Uh first priority
I don't feel like going all the way over there. Just yeah, maybe
I'm not really worried about going over here because
Unless I need something from there. I'm not gonna go over there the weeping peninsula. Um
I believe the other map is over here
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know
And I could yeah, and then I gotta go up
And then yes, I do need to don't I need to kill him to well, I could go the cheatzy doodle way
To get to
What's it called?
I don't have to fight him to go through there and I would honestly rather not
I'd rather take the road around
The hills
To do that, but I forget how to do that
I like that. I remember like important things and then I just don't remember how to enact them
Under psychic yeah, I need to do that
Uh
No, I'm not I'm not summoning anybody summoning anyone right yet just yet. Um
We ride and period wife gone
Yeah, weeping is good for far. I did farm a lot in the weeping peninsula. I recall
Um
Sorry, it's moving my obs window so I can see it better
Okay, uh, I believe there's a map fuck. Why does it keep doing that?
There's a map
Somewhere in this direction
So I will go over there. We ride at dawn except it's nighttime
I love running simulator
It's my favorite
Riding horse riding simulator after a big jar lad quest you can't forget. Oh, fuck you're right. I gotta do a lot of shit. Ah
There's important quests I need to do
Because I need to get the wonder psychic it's physics physics psychic. I forget where that is
We ride at night, um
Um
Yeah, I need to talk to blive. I need to talk to in my home boy blive at some point
Damn, there's so much to fucking do in this game. Why am I oh my I have bonus runes right now
Um
Gotta do a lot of stuff
A lot of stuff. Let me just focus on maps. I think maps
Yeah, the maps right over here. That's what it is. Let me do that. Fuck you
I wish we needed to lead it. It would just switch to that
To one instead of two
All right, let's fucking do it focusing on the maps and then we'll know our way around
Honestly, when I labeled it when I get all the maps, I'll be able to know where the fuck I'm going and have a bigger better plan
Let me not jump off cliffs
Um, I'm debating whether or not to just speedrun
Because again, I've played the game before I've beaten the game before
I'm I am very tempted just to focus on a build
And worry about defeating uh, radon and moog
Damn why the maps are fucking far? Oh
Shit, oh, oh shit. I have to go over the bridge. Let's see night rider
I could have teleported but you know, I prefer the scenic rope, you know scenic ropes nice. Oh fuck me bro. No
Get away. Get away. Get away
I'm not really a speedrunner to be honest with you. I don't I don't speedrun anything
Get off my butt. Oh shit. I got it. Oh fuck. Oh shit. Oh, we're fine
I'm kind of wishing that I played a little bit before like on my ps5 before I started over here just so I can
Have more of my bearings
Hello mouse thing
Oh, yeah, that's
Let me grab this gray
Grace
Torrent go away. Thank you torrent
Fun trivia fact at night those who are yet dead are revived due to lack of the sun and presence
Supposedly any clips has something to do with it. Huh?
Everybody's came for it. Yes
No, I didn't just explain anything that I want to do in all my plans. I've never played this. What is elden ring?
I'm so new to this
This is when you become a muppet. I've always been a muppet. I don't know what you're talking about
I can't I recall I believe I skipped mogue in my playthrough initially
Um, hello bear. I'm just gonna
Oh, I'm like, what do I hear my monitor fucking sucks and uh
I can't see anything
Especially because I have a window behind it. So it's like kind of fucking me up. Okay
Perfect, perfect
I just want the maps. That's all I care about is the maps
I might go up into cali if I feel like it
And
Because then I also have to consider
I also have to get like more flasks. I have to get the like I have to get stuff that I need I need to level up
Can you please stop scratching that damn thing so loud, bro
I
Might go talk to the crown because I remember I think she can tells you where to go for that
Oh, he's going at that tree. He was he was going for it
She be entered and got a long chore list. Okay, and I do
I have to cut through here because it's fucking stupid
I can't remember if I have to beat this fucking guy drops down
Oh, I'm not gonna fucking bother with you, dude. Oh fucking bro
Uh-huh, you are expecting me to come from the other side
Because I got like golden seeds I need to get all right, um
Oh
No, it's the fucking air wolves. Uh, I always think it's funny. They howl and they just like fucking up here
And then they just fucking I was trying to sit down
Oh, you fucking son of a bitch get the fuck out. I swear to god
Oh get out of here, dude. I can't even I'm not even locking on you properly because I'm just irritated
Can I please wolf quest gamers. I'm fighting off wolf quest gamers
That's what's really an additional payday is you have to go on finding yeah, yeah, yeah
You have to find your resources ASMR. She be featuring fear right at him for me
It'd be fear getting stuck on something boomy chewing on a box and then rena screaming
or purring
Hey you
Everyone's been grafted. I'm so sorry
They crossed the sea for me they fought
For me. Are you a princess? By the way, I always wondered that because I'm like, why did all these people die for her?
their legs taken even their heads. Oh, they've gotten grafted
Godric the grafted or the fucking name is godfrey god something god go good. Geodric
By the spider you become a chrysalid. Oh, you're high. When you think it's quite the lock when you think about it
cool
Is it I have never experienced it. Have you I want to be like everyone else, but I'm just oh you want to be grafted
But a craven
I'm so sorry
Thank you for the jellyfish
I'm sorry. I didn't mean to like attack you
How do you know that it'll be glad if you're I got grafted
Yeah, I'll kill you
What the fuck are you
On this
What are you talking about
Oh, okay
Honestly, some of the shit the dialogue in this game is so fucking dark
Yeah, I can do that for you
Oh
Me met it where she's like, oh, I get you tiny pellet golf out my face
The jellyfish carried you in your first playthrough. That's adorable
I was thinking about when she tried to smack her oh awkward
I think I know it's kind of I saw that uh, they're considering doing a
Uh unofficial anime adaptation of this and weirdly enough
Weirdly enough
I would prefer a live action adaptation
I don't know why
It would be a lot
Of CGI
And it would definitely probably be easy, but I don't know what I would prefer a live action
I don't know if it's just me
I think
I don't know. Maybe I'm just hankering for a new fantasy thing to watch
Uh, where am I going?
All right, I'm going to the cruel
Torrent to me
Guys, I think I'm gonna order pizza. What do you think?
It's because you guys gave me the pizza stuff
Oh, yeah, there's all the fucking bloody fingers. I got a fucking fight. Jesus Christ, bro
I've got so much shit to do
I don't have a time. Oh fuck off you bat
I
Feel like she's the one who tells me where to go because you go along the edge to get to
Hey
You want my fingies, let me get your toes then I like how you're gripping the side of this table
I'm gonna just take a cheese pizza
Yeah, definitely a series wouldn't want it to be a movie
Your fingers give me your fingers. I want to last my maidenhood with your two fingers
Even tight
And reunites the half
presents
at the grand lift
Pete's funds cleared pizza funds cleared ladies and gentlemen
That's crazy, um
Damn, that's crazy. Anyways
I'm
Somebody put something oh, they just put something there
Hey
Oh, you fucking died. Why did you die? Oh
They jumped off that side. Oh, it's funny
I
Rump ahead
Oh hitting path
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and you get a hitting path and all that I'm gonna fall off or something because I can't see properly
It's this isn't it
Because I can totally circumvent
How do I do it though? There's a way to get along the edge and I thought it was
No
I was turning around. Okay, well
Let's go get our shit. Well, that's not the way
At least I wasn't far. Oh, yes gravity the final boss
I
Have to remember
Fuck not how to fuck. Um, I have to remember. Is it up around here?
That's why I fucking know it
Right, oh don't about it
Oh don't about it. Oh don't about it. I'm thinking about it. I'm thinking
I'm funkin
Well, let's oh my god, I almost did it again
Let's not go that way. Let's not let's not do it that way. Let me go get my rune since
I usually normally wouldn't give a shit and I'll just leave them but because I'm such a low level every rune counts
Gravity zone defeated. I'm gonna be like this one guy and just totally running a circle off
Oh
Wait, I kind of should kill you. Oh, I'm kind of
Well, that's awkward anyways
Dismount dismount. Yeah, no fucking shit, dude
I'm a little slow in the head. Relax, bro
And do we do we wait you can't get back up from here
If you can't get back up from here that might mean something what did you do?
I didn't mean to pick that up, but it's fine
Did you fall off? Oh right there. That's where you fell off
Cliff ahead. Oh, I would have who would have thunk to be honest
Where is oh found it found it found it found the hidden path ha ha ha ha found the hidden path
My ear itches
Beware wolves. Okay, hold on. Let me let me do something. Let me do something real quick
I have played the game
Yes, I played the game before I am doing a faith intel build
I
Will ask for help when I need it cunt
Wow, isn't that fabulous
Put this like I just had this constantly scrolling
It was center of my screen
How about that?
It's a smaller
Accelerate it too big. What the fuck?
Why did it flip? Oh, what happened?
Oh, I didn't know I could do that
Oh
There you go
Perfect Wow
Perfect golden upside down to establish dominance
For the stupid fucking zit in my ear
hurts
Somebody come pop it with their mouth. How about that?
Back to you just be gone. It's not even back seating
It's just people like being like hey like they're trying to like warn me or like tell me like like hint at something
Which is like what you should do if you're going to do anything
Like if you're gonna like you can give a hint, you know, if the backseat which is which I appreciate
But I'm like I already know I already know that wolves are gonna fucking fall from the sky and howl and be like
And try to kill me
I already know all this shit
I just have a bad memory of when things happen
Oh, this little guy's coming with me. Hi. Oh my god, you're so sweet. Don't fall off
Hey puppies. Hi. Sorry. Hold on. Um, I'll see you in a bit
Um, I'm trying to just do stuff
Hugging the fucking wall
Hi other puppies
Same bro
Throw me to the wolves and I'll come back leader of the pack and pregnant
Be dee dee dee. I kind of sworn there's a white wolf there though. Oh my god, where am I wait? What's that?
Let me grab this shit. I was crystal but I don't really care
How convenient liarnia, that's what it's called
I found this path on accident, I believe
Omg she be I love you. Please put your hand to me
Do wolves try to regularly try to ambush you they always they just they just smell my heat because I'm a rabbit
I'm constantly in heat, you know
It's funny saying this is a Muppet
And they always they just try to they just try to get me they just try to come for me and you know, I have to tell them to
Chill out, you know
All right, where's the map for the
I'm the map. I'm the map. I'm the map
All the way down there. Fuck me brother. I forget how to do shit. Okay
Whoopsies I forgot how to get down
I can jump right I can just jump off
Stupid
I wish torrent could fly
I wish I could drop a water bucket like it's minecraft
I could I had to go down that way. Don't I guess I do. Hello baddies. Excuse me baddies. Sorry. Sorry
Uh, let me go into this chat because there's something that I need here
I
Just like gritty
I'm not allowed to talk. Sorry. I can't talk to you while I'm half a lot of horse
I don't know what gave you the idea. I'm sorry. My titties are in your face
Sure, here you go
Yeah, don't I look like one hopes. I'm sorry. My sword is in your sleeve. I can teach you sorceries as promised. Nice
None of them are particularly great. Then why the fuck are you telling me?
Okay, perfect. I'll come to you go to for those later when I get more money
Uh, I might I'm I am thinking about bouncing over to calid
uh
Doing trying I have to I have to farm a golden scarab bounce over to calid kill that little dragons with sleeping
um
So I can get some extra runes and then I'll level up a little bit
And I literally just have to farm
I'm literally just I'm trying to think of like
The fastest and easiest way to go through things but then again
Like people have said like you what are you starting over?
Like I literally essentially almost have to play through the entire game again
Like I don't but I do, you know, I don't know if that makes any fucking sense
I do but I don't
All right, torrent. Let's try our platforming skills. Where's the
Where's the little thingies?
Other right here, okay
To me
Um
What the sigma how do I there has to be one closer up isn't there
These are too far down because I know yeah, I can already tell people tried to fucking
Wait what I didn't really see what happened to him
Oh, then you just jumped off. Okay, so you did make that
Okay, that makes sense. All right. Um
Hmm
Try to think of the path I want to go because I could just be like who
But then I need to go into the center of the fucking lake
So yeah, I should keep going down
We're going down down in an early around fuck. I can't platform for shit and torrent is really hard to control
Oh
We did it. Yeah, I see mo we did it
Fuck
Fuck me, I mean
Uh, I forgot is there another grace over here there is there definitely is I know there's another grace over here
I just can't remember where it is
I
Excuse me. Have you guys seen a grace? Is there a grace around here? Oh fuck. Is there a great? I'm on fire
I'm on fire. Uh, is there a grace?
Excuse me
Have you have you happened to see a grace mr. Troll?
Mr. Troll, have you seen a grace?
I I like to talk to you be our lord and save you jesus christ
Are you guarding something I can't remember
Uh, hold on hold on
Hold on hold on
To me torrent to me
I
My nose itches
I don't think brother wants to talk
What the fuck is that
Somebody's car. I was like what the hell what was the game? I'm like, I don't remember this part of the soundtrack
Our call he had a chance to make a new school source. He was not gonna give him the chance
He had the chance
Was not giving the chance
Hold on let me let me get my bearings real quick
Maybe I should start using that mimic grace. Oh wait, there's a grace right there
I'm like where's the grace
The grace sparkles
I got a two
Let me see if I can muffle the two
Ha ha you could not hear it. No, I didn't have to mute
How the fuck did you get over here so fast?
Testing my limits, huh?
I can handle anything
Look, I'm what I'm I have the medal. It's on my head
Yeah, it seems my worries were unfounded. You are not even a real maiden. So I don't even know where this came from
Whereas I merely pretend
There is but one other thing I can do to offer you guidance and what's that?
I can take you to the round table. Is that true gathering place
of tarnished champions
Guided by grace. That's crazy
Let's go. Let my hand rest upon you for buttermilk resting in glasses. I'm wearing glasses
Time to go to Walmart
Wow
Wowie Zowie
Hey
Wow, I really don't need to be here right now
What's your name again?
Dia Dia something. Ah, hello
He must be new here. Yeah
Well, just call me Dia Los. Dia Los. Hello Dia Los. I remember
I was doing your
Little quest off to the side and I really liked it and it was really sad. Take your eyes off for for but a moment
Yep, like me. Bye
Um, I could fight this dude
I'll I don't feel like doing all the shit over again. I wish I could import my save from my playstation. That would literally be
amazing
Oh, hey, it's you. Oh, sorry. I didn't mean to jump. I was jumping for joy
Glad to see that you're why are you taller than me?
I should have told you sooner. It's okay, Roderica
I like your name Roderica
Why do I look so fucked up?
Uh, we all know how it's gonna end I become the elderboard the lordess if you will
Yeah, well your purpose is to level up my spirit ashes. I'll spoil that for you. Uh, hello
It's block shot. Okay. I'm just I'm just gonna see what I can open before I do anything
Oh, yeah, it's you who just stares at me
I always loved his fucking armor. I remember I I got it at some point
I don't even know who the fuck this guy is like. I don't know anything about him
I don't I don't think I followed anything that he does
His door was block shot
I think I remember the last thing I would play it was playing was the dung eater. I was doing the dung eater quest
Uh, I don't know I'm here yet
All right, let's let's let's uh
Uh
I do need some runes
I just wanna
I just think of that picture of that one meme of all the guys pointing their swords at the table
I just think of that every time I'm here
Um
I how much runes do I have?
I have 400. Um, let me say
Yeah, everyone should use it
It's still not enough, uh, did I have any more?
Is that enough to level up I think not
Okay, no it is enough. Um
I like I just broke the chair. I could have sat in oh it came back. It's fine
All right, um, again, I am really just going to work on raising my vigor right now, so I'm gonna do that
Uh
And you know, I bet you guys are hankering for a fight
I'm up at sheepy is my kind of room
Uh
Oh man, imagine if I could sit in a chair. I'd be kind of cool for a hub role thing
Sometimes when I go to hug fia and I get a degree a concert thigh and the bouncer's pull me off
It's stop the runes out of me. God damn bro. I always get turned around in here though
I
What are you buying?
What are you selling?
That's me
Lay out your arms
I don't really want to do that because I'd rather find a sword
Open the door I can't open it yet
Where's fia
Uh, pretty sure these doors are all shut still. Yeah, because I have to beat the guy
Yeah, okay, let's do a little fighty fight
Let's fight this bloody finger
Because I've been I've been skipping through stuff because I want to get out a good spot
But I'm like, you know what you guys deserve it. You deserve a good fight, you know
But he's locked in me taking him literally and putting my actual arms under the hammer
Superhero landing, let's go
Oh, I mean
Oh, that's crazy
I love your little sword
We're just gonna do this whole time
It's a riveting fight
Oh no, ah frostbite I shouldn't have walked through that
Stop casting frostbite
I'm already dead
He was a scythe no, it's a sith actually he's a sith lord
Go back I'm gonna fucking rest
Yes, well, I'm gonna do it I'm gonna whip your bomb I'm not gonna wipe it I'm gonna whip it
I
Invaded my mat tongue albric
Whoa
Have fun with that
Oh you dodged it
To complain that game
Oh, oh
You're a sneaky little bugger, aren't you? I'm not used to doing an intelligence sort of build
Time goes by
So, so I walked into that oh no, oh fucking hell hold on hold on
Oh no
Locked in
Oh, hold on oh, oh you motherfucker. I forgot you could heal
Oh, come on
Can you stop
Can we have a timeout please can we have a can we have a quick timeout?
Thank you for backing up that's really respectful of you
Ow
All right
Locked in muppet she be she be getting in the mix
Getting
Getting something he's hacking he has hacks bro his his wall hacks on bro. Come on bro. You see it bro
I'm gonna come back and beat his ass, okay
Well, there's your time out
Hey
Um, let's actually
Actually run through
I just want to get on the maps bro. Let's go back to where we were
I'm up at she be just in strike fear
I was gonna do is my patreon voice my sexy patreon voice what I thought about you
Kind of too silly is a muppet
Keep it a stack
Gotta got fans
I'm like drop keep it a stack
A little bit of east piece a little bit of ice spice a little east piece
So a little speasy speasy a little icy spicy
I see spicy bodicey
Banana fennef will feisty
Gotta get down get some map icy
Gotta get that my pussy
with dizzy little loosey
And i'm gonna get a concussy
We're almost there russie
I'm not the theme to audio then
Hi, i'm steven. I'm about it. I love to be here
There is
Hello, excuse me. Uh, no, excuse. Excuse me. Excuse. Uh, I'm just
Trying to pick up a map
Here there's a map around here. Is that is that correct?
Oh, I don't know why I pressed that button
Oh, what that's right here. Thank you. I appreciate you pointing that out to me really appreciate
I got a girl
I got stuff to do. Oh, it's been real cool
Really handy hanging out with y'all
Oh, fuck it's a lobster
Ah
I didn't know this was going to be a horror game. Oh my god
One two, uh, uh, uh
All right
One two, three, scuttle
Yeah, no shit. Uh, okay. Where's the other map?
It's over here. Oh
This map is such a bitch to get because it's like up here near the towers the bell tower whatever fucks
um
Somebody wants to be the world with macaroni
Hmm
I'm gonna go unlock the weeping peninsula just because I'm like I'm a completionist in this way in terms of like
I don't want to be able to see everything, you know
So really this order of pizza sort of snacking on these little crackers
I
Somebody wants to roll me
I'm bounding down and downy
I'm stimming us
I I
I
Stop it. I'm not stimming
Maybe
Excuse me
Yeah, I know
I heard
That was a peninsula that wipes around here. I forget what I did last time, but I somehow managed to end up on the other side of this
Before like unlocking it and shit, and I don't know how I managed that
Because there is a there's another way to get on the weeping peninsula. I just couldn't recall. Hey, uh, something about your dad
Oh, yeah, you're blind
I swear I heard frightful howling my good father secreted me at the castle. He did you or sequestered you secreted you secret
Torrent hello, you good now stand on his body. He's fine. He's just napping. He's napping everyone relax
You pick up some stuff
Um
Yeah, I know is there anything in here I cannot recall remember those fucking dogs. Yeah, good ass dogs
Um, there is
um, let me just
Come on
Come on shake a body and I'll do that gunga. No, take a body. I don't any longer
I know it's the morning star that's in there. I don't
I don't really feel like getting ashes of war right now
Perfect
Let's grace get the grace grace grace
She's gojo from it. Oh my god, it's gojo
Question to raise here. How does gal even write in her note? That's a great question
Maybe she had some braille
Secreted from the parents. She basically was gonna do blind gal's quest. No, I'm not I'm probably not gonna do her quest
Although I have to go to cast a mourn anyways, don't I for other shit? I don't know
I need it
I have zero rooms
I need to find can someone look up for me
Jamie get on this look up
The nearest golden scarab
Are
The thing that boosts my rooms, I can't remember what's called. It's a golden scarab, isn't it? Oh, I forgot you were there
Hey, what's up, bro?
Hit me hit me
Ha ha you missed you're a terrible shot
Come on come on then
Show me what you got
That wasn't even fucking near me, bro. Jesus fucking Christ
It's chicken foot. It's a cave
Oh, yes, you're right. It is the chicken foot. It's not the golden scarab. It's chicken foot the golden scarab is a amulet, isn't it?
All right
Why am I still locked in? Oh this matter. Hey, what's up, bro?
I'm sorry. I can't talk to you. You're fighting something
I'm just gonna leave just want to see how you're doing. Please. How am I still locked in something with him?
There we go, uh cool cool cool cool. We love to see it
All right, and I need to go
Up and around
It would be I need to go up this way and do gaelid
Or
I can go to the church america and get into that fucking shitty plane
No, I'd rather not do that because I hate that place and I'm so low level. I die in like five seconds
Um, so we're gonna teleport over here and we're gonna follow this road all the way down
We're gonna go around this fucking shit
And then we're gonna go and then we're gonna go over here and we're gonna talk to this lady probably
I don't know
And uh, yeah, that's it. It'll be a great time. It'll be a real great time
Wait
I need to go to church america because I need to get phone
Why is my phone almost dead?
Wondrous physics, where is it?
I
Okay, I should actually go over to there first
Yeah, let's do that
Yeah
Yep, yep, yep
Okay, it's a church america. Let me just
Let's go
I'm sorry. I'm trying to set myself up for success before I like legit go for anything
that's it's
The first like the first few playthroughs of this might be a little bit grindies. I try to get my level up
What's up big
Who am I fighting who is oh is that the troll?
Are the experience no, I mean like um
Because I bet you're expecting me I know like every time I've watched a playthrough of this game
Or just watch somebody start it. They just fight the fucking tree sentinel for five hours
All right sick nasty
Reach out and touch marker
Um, because you know the temptation is there
It's a ride of passage
All right
And then we're gonna talk to this bitch. I'm a shithead. I brought you another chord. This one's better
I don't want to hear them
Of course tell me
Yep, that's cool. Um
I got shit to do so can you could leave now?
I thought I had a golden seed, but I don't ever use it. That's right
Come back
I want to do horrible things to you
Bro, I need to look up some
Melina
Melina Melina shit. Oh spicy
um
Oh
Where was it?
There's a little
Little grotto. I believe it's on this side. Yes
Jump through this
And then we can go in here. Yep. Yep. Yep
And
Find a cheeky little pole. Oh wait. No, this portal goes somewhere else, doesn't it?
This portal goes to where that giant thing is
Yeah, doesn't it take you all the way to fucking oh, perfect
I swear to god, it did not bring you here before
Anyways, um, honestly, these are some of my favorite minibosses are the little gargoyle guys
Another thing I skipped in the game when I beat it is I never actually went to um
I don't even remember what it's called
Aramizula
Not those little fuckers. All right. Oh wait. No, I need to get the chicken feet before I do this. Let's find a grace first
There's a grace nearby there's a grace nearby over the bridge after the dragon
I think oh, it's right here. Perfect actually
Yeah
I could remember if there was a chest in that little area or if there was
That takes you to the cilia crystal caves or if it took you
To where the grand lift is but not on the right part of it. I mean the capital
Hi, Rina
What's up, mama
Rina has like the craziest fucking gash on her next to her booty hole
And I asked the doctor. I'm like, uh, do we got to do anything with that? And they're like, nah, it'll scab over
I'm like, you don't have to stitch that or nothing like
Come on. They're like, no, she's good. I'm like, okay
All right. Oh, hey, it's strani. Hello strani. How's it going? What is this a plate? Uh
A
mother I have to explain
Uh
I don't really know
how to explain
My transformation. Why are you brave? I'm always brave. What are you talking about? I've always been a break. I'm always a break
Hi, shebe. How's it good lord? What happened to you?
I've been mummified. How does that make you feel?
Do you like it? Do you like my muppet body?
Do you want to touch my muppet body?
Do you want to stick your hand in my muppet body?
Yeah, this um, so ellen ring kind of taxes my pc on top of
Vtube studio, so I was in call of tomokies
And she's like, hold on. Let me whip you up something real quick
for a little png
And she made I was just going to draw myself as like a little floor sock puppet thing
And then she's like, no, I got you. I'll do even better
And then so she drew me as this
Princess pig lady miss piggy
Are you bringing sesame straight to elton ring?
Sesame street is different from the muppets, but go off this
um
Okay, uh, where is the nearest golden chicken foot?
What is that bush doing?
Hello, what's happening to this tree?
Is this tree okay?
It's not raining that hard. Why is it shaking so feverishly?
Tree is vibing cursed
Oh
What that bush doing? What that bush doing?
Busting it down was a down tree tree tiana
Sharni gonna come away from the stream
Yeah, tommy did a great job. Um, I'm going to look up the nearest chicken foot
You
Old pickled fowl pot
It can be found in westland grave
All right
All right, it's right over there. It's actually not that far
It's got spiffy thoth
Where was it? Where is it? Where is it? Oh, it's right over here the waypoint ruins. Uh, okay
Yeah
You like how I look you like my body
You want to touch my little muppet body?
I hate saying muppet body. It's so weird. Okay, let me go over here the waypoint ruins
Oh torrent
We got to go find ourselves a golden pickled foot
Do a kermit boys
Uh, hello
It is I kermit defrock
I can't really do kermit that much. Hello
Excuse me pardon me. Excuse me. Sorry. Oh, I'm so sorry. I heard you. I see that you guys are really busy
uh
Wait, I think they have what I need because I need a bleed
I need a bleed thing to kill that fucking dragon faster. Um, all right
Hmm fascinating hold on. I must read something. I must read to see where this is in the waypoint ruins
The base of the crucifix on a small hill in westland grave
Based of a crucifix. Can I have a picture?
Oh, come on
Where oh fuck if I do images I'm better with images
Watch
Jesus Christ, okay
Oh, okay, that's where it is. I love it when people don't say anything. They just show you where it is
That's my favorite type of youtube video
Okay, uh, here it is just a little bit over here
Needly I can't remember
Oh
Fuck off
Uh, get out of my face. Oh, uh, hold on
Hold on. I'm doing something
I can't open this. There's nothing in here that I can I get
Out
Raina you're not helping. She's like walking all over me
Cool, um, I could have sworn I can get the thing in this you're lying to me that I can
No
Oh
Zippity-doodle zippity-day my oh my
How you guys doing? Damn you have those things drove driven in your chest
That sucks
That doesn't seem fun
The guys need to stop. Oh, that's right. You're right. You're right. Um
Hey, I need to you to fucking stop
You stop. Thank you
Fucking stop. No, don't hit me stop stop stop stop stop
Excuse me. Hold on. I'm busy. I'm busy. I'm picking it up. Oh, it's not what I wanted. Um, that was kind of worthless
Oh
Uh, maybe it was
Yes, actually. Yes, it was. Uh, I need to go
To a different place. I need to go
To where can I open my map? Nope. Come on, please. Do you aggro?
Doesn't make any sense. Yeah, I know I feel like you should just be able to hop
On it and just take it out. I don't know. I can't do that
All right
No
Still no, okay
I think I'm absolutely far away enough
Jesus Christ
Is this is this is it the turtle? Is it the turtle that's aggroing me right now? Oh, thank god. Um, I need to go
To
Where that one place was, oh my god, where is it? Uh, you have to
Where that lady is at Weeping Peninsula, okay
Okay, um
I wish I could just teleport to where that'd be great
Because it's right. Yeah, I just have to cut
Rue because that's where the
Is it the morning star?
Yes, I saw that run I saw that little little blurb when I was looking I only needed one I only needed one. Um
I need to go to her
I'm just using her as a marker. I don't I need to actually go to her but
Because I need to get
Because like oh, I could go do a dungeon to get the
Hey, hi, oh my god. Hey. Oh wait, is there something in here that I can ask? Oh my god. Hold on. Stop. Stop it right now
I got shit to do
Yo, oh
Oh
Uh
Never mind. What just happened?
Um
I don't recall the thing breaking like that to be honest with you, but
Are you do that you do you? Where am I going this way?
Oh, I went to the wrong fucking one. It's fine
Hey, can I like take your shit?
Thank you
Um
What
I know because I'm hi mom because I'm using fuji tech
To do my muppet
Can you hear me? Yeah
That's why it says live mic warding
Oh
My chat says hello straw knee
I like your muppet joke. Yeah, I do want to put my hands in you. Good night, shebie
Good night
Maybe I'll ask mona son to make one for fuji tech like a voice channel for that. Um
I've gotten so distracted. I don't know where I'm supposed to go
Oh, I got went so far away. I'm sorry. Let me go back
He's trying to jump scare wait, I want to see is this her is
No, she left
I
Felt like my mom just walked in on me doing stuff. Are you supposed to be in here?
All right that crab is looking at me funny
What do you do in crabbo you mess with the crabbo you get the stabbo
No, there's another one never got about that
What I really need to get is bloodhound step fuck I just got ganked
What I want I get I could go to the jail
And kill that dude because I love
I use that weapon for like the majority of my run. Um until I get the halo scythe
I know you like crab
Oh, there's a bunch of baby crabs
Where's my marker it's down that way. Oh my god, there's so many
I generally do not recall there being three. I thought there was only two
Hello shapees. I want to see you roll away. No, okay
Two crap one rabbit. Oh my god, maybe I'll get some crap. Oh the jail's right there actually
temptation
Oh
I could try to kill him because I do like the bloodhounds fang
How much
I only have five runes. Oh, it's fucking yeah, it's fucking loose
Let's see food fights back
Okay, where's he come out of hello, you need me
Oh
Again, I'm not used to uh intel blood loss. I'm already dead
Blood loss
Now it's quick listen, uh, I would actually should be doing I should be parrying so let me do that
Why do I still have effects on me?
Wow my whole five whopping runes
All right, I need to adjust my butt is hurt take
Okay, ow when you're a woman and you move a certain way you almost like hurt yourself in the kuchi
Are you now are you gonna stay there actually I kind of need to pee
Let me just back
I want to put you down miss ma'am hang out
And I'm gonna pee pee pee pee pee then if anybody comes to discord call they can hear me pee
So
Every time you saw my Muppet light out
Light up this pretend I was ripping ass and the microphone was making it up. Oh my god the fucking car scared me
No
It's not even like when I was talking about like you get a little pain
It's like you get like a cramp like in your uterus by just moving the wrong way it sucks
I'm just trying to re-enter the call. No, she went to sleep. She went to sleep. She's a good night
She it's like fucking what time is it for her right now? Let me look
I
I'm smart and I have everybody's clocks
Uh world clocks on my phone so I can see where people are awake and guess
Yeah, it's fucking 9 a.m. For her and she's going to sleep
Yeah, she does keep vampire hours. Let me lean back in my chair a little bit
Yeah, cuz I like because I don't like
Wait like trying to figure out what time people are at or like what time it is for someone
Um, because then I could just look
Then just like
Do the math a little bit
I am comfy. I'm lean back in my chair. My legs are up. I am flourishing. I am fabulous
I'm charging my phone
I am actually I don't think I
I feel like I should order a pizza now
True gamer hours ordering a pizza
Fucked up sleep schedule. Okay, I know I'm gonna go fucked up sleep schedule
Uh
I don't know. Where should I order pizza from?
Give me suggestions. Where should I order pizza from?
I'm covered in my blinky. I'm so comfy
I took a shower today. I smell delicious
Papa John's
There is a Papa John's in me. I think
I
Pizzeria
The hut I've
There was like one pizza hut in my area and it went out of business. So just like never showed up. I have they don't really have
Papa geno's. I think there's a Papa geno's my local place
Local places are it's pretty good. They're all right
Trying to think of like the best local place
I
Like a sweet sauce
Can't recall
which out of
the three Papa geno's Papa John's and
Papa Domino's has sweet sauce ever get
I'm not a huge fan of deep dish
I think it's too saucy. It's too much. It's too thick
You think Papa John's has a sweet sauce or Domino's? I don't know. I can't remember
So like I don't know. Have you guys ever had like beach pizza?
Is that or is that just an east coast thing?
Beach pizza
No
Oh, um, I don't
Really know how to explain it
So beach pizza. It's really tasty. It's sound it's um
It's really it's square cut pizza with really nice sweet sauce and
um
They have they just throw like a slice of provolone on it. It's just so good and we call it beach pizza
Because usually you can get it on at the beach
It's not there's not like the actual like that's not the like the company that makes it
It's just call it just colloquially
Call beach pizza and you can get like ham and shit and like extra provolone
It's pretty good
It's really tasty
It's like the sharpness of the little bit of sharpness from the provolone and then like the sweeter sauce is really tasty
You have marcos? No. It must be an American thing. I think it is
I'm gonna like
Cause I feel like
I'm gonna look off the name of the place I should get it from
But I'm checking to see if it's family owned
Or if it's everywhere
Oh, yeah
Um
Okay, that's
That would be such a pain to like it would be so expensive for just a few slices
But it's not it's not that it's not it's different than that
It's similar but it's not it's like
But I'm gonna stop describing it because I feel like it will
You'll be able to find where I am. Um, okay
Enter ever jail I always wanted I used to call it ever goal
And whatever it is it looks great
Um, let me go on swords ash and let me get some pizza
Oh, I didn't mean to do that. Oh fuck. I might have accidentally just marked it something is bad
No, I didn't mean to do that
Oh
Accidentally was like rate your last food and I was like accidentally put three stars when I was cleaning three stuff
I could order some little Caesars
Oh my god, I can't order Pizza Hut. What the hell
What the hell there's so much they have so much shit. I think I'm Cinnabon mini rolls. What the fuck
I am getting diabetes just looking at their menu. Holy shit
I did not I've never had Pizza Hut before
I think I'm gonna order Pizza Hut just because I've never had it before
I
Didn't find I was pronounced jail after watching British streamer because apparently it's more commonly known there. Yeah, I think I think that's how I found it out too
Big fan of the hut. Yeah
It's bottom to your Pete secret coming out of left field screaming it's bottom to your pizza
Pizza Hut
What what in hut pizza hut he is always giving me food points. Okay, I never mind
I don't need food poisoning for the 50th time in my life
Uh this week
Like a pizza
Oh, if I order from here, oh, it's so expensive
I'm I know I need to eat but I'm actually getting nauseous looking at food right now
I think I might just have soup
Oh, no, but those soup plays they ordered from those really good as closed
I
Guess I'll starve
Actually like the crust on dominoes sandwich
sandwich
Say pizza for the collab with Toma making a pizza party. That's cute. Actually
I think I'll just make my soup self some soup later because I have some chicken noodle soup like some Campbell's
I think that'll be good for me
When I have some um oyster crackers left over from
The last place I ordered from yes
Toma knows how sandwiches dominoes is really greasy. I usually have to pack the pizza
All right, I'm ready
I'm ready. I'm ready. I'm so ready
I
I'm already dead
Guys, I think I lost guys. I think I need to be a little bit stronger
Guys
Just a warm-up just a warm-up
Just take an IV trip for a new nutrition. Why is it make me go all the way over here?
I
Like bonking them and then they explode
Look at it. He's being silly
Always coming towards me that's awkward anyways
Are you the one of those summons is cheating kind of players no I usually
I usually like abuse the fuck out of my mimics here
Um
That's really about it. No, I think about it. What the fuck? Oh, he's confused the fuck out of me for a second
Can you come up please?
I don't remember his moveset. Oh, yep. That's right
This will spin you're so fast bro. You're so fast. I I held up. I held this up
Okay, this isn't gonna work out
Five guys shield summon
One hit clap
Oh
Yeah, let's just continue to how we were going
I'll come for that bloodhounds fang later
I'll just get the warning star first. I need something that it does bleed
Sack
Pizza fun. Oh, thank you future pizza fun
I should just have something added to my throne and just be like pizza fun
Oh speaking of throne, uh, I was thinking
Uh, I'm kind of like I don't really need anything else anymore
So I just add stuff that I need for my house
um
And I'm wondering if I should start doing what Amy did and start saving for a 2.0
Because I kind of just want I kind of want a model that's like more me
I love this one, especially when I am in my Muppet form
That's on this side. Please don't attack me. Please don't attack me. Please don't attack me
All right, now we can go to Kaleid. We have what we need
Actually it's up here
This is where I need to go too. I forget how big Kaleid is
I thought I thought this game was so huge like I thought
Um, just limb grief and weeping peninsula. We're gonna be the whole tarry game and I was so wrong
Yeah, I'm already getting a
tan model with um, that's what I mean if I'm in a couple weeks or so
So I hope it not good enough. I love the Muppet actually. I would just have a straight-up Muppet model
So beyond me and Tom are talking. I'm like, I wish there were more cartoony models out there like
I'm someone I don't like
Westernized
Anime style models, but I do like cartoony models. There's a difference. There's a difference in that
Hello
Grail
You say pizza I say
Filling sandwich supreme
Thank you. Thank you so much said
Dastoy
Sounds like dastardly
All right, um, I forget where you go after this
Pretty sure you go past
Really doing this all by memory. My memory's not good. Oh, you'll pass this tree
We'll pass the minor or a tree
With a little funky guy
Nevermind
I died
Oh
And that's what this would be like a thing that would be later on like this would be like towards like the fall
Probably actually
Maybe for my birthday because my birthday's in um
In September it's September 28. I probably don't want maybe model before then as a little tree, you know
Um, then you go around do you go up if you go up again? I'm doing this all my fucking memory
There you go
Oh, what the hell how are you hitting me? No
Don't pass these dudes
Yes, here we are. Okay. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Hi
Hello, sweetie. I'm so sorry. I'm gonna put you out of your misery. Okay
All right
Oh, I forgot you summon other dragons
I'm gonna come right over here
Here dragons
I forget the story with this one
Anyways, top grade in here. I'm gonna kill you for doing that
Okay
2.0 actually not even like a one point. Well actually honestly my toggle update be like a 1.5
I am hidden in your wing. Nobody can find me
But I'm maybe even later. I don't even know because again, I know stronti put a lot of money into this model. So I don't want to like
Take it for granted or seem like I am because I like this model like I like
I'm not the model. That's a muppet. Um
I don't know just something more me
Oh
I can wield this with both hands. How do I double how do I double hand wield something I totally forget
I totally forget how to do that
Oh
What
Oh, yeah, okay. No, why is it doing this?
Oh
Can I put this on my
I don't I don't want to use this
There we go
Stop yelling I'm trying to kill you
It's my take a while
Where's the best spot I mean, this is a good spot. This is not a good spot. Um, hold on
Hold on. I'm thinking
You're like in the ground in the ground
I don't see what this guy says
Why does it always talk
You really attack her it's a girl
You're gonna you're gonna you want my muppet body you're gonna you're gonna do stuff to this muppet you're gonna leave me nice and crusty
Like your song
Oh
I don't want to attack by the tail
It's because I feel like all this magically aggro something somehow
Oh, what's the matter? What do you mean?
I feel like in lower wind tarnish is doing this the tarnish is burning their way into the dragon's body
Oh
I need to look up what her deal is though because I know there's like another thing you can do with this dragon
She's just here just for farming
Oh
Oh, she's grail the braille
Well, thankfully, um, are you talking in leech?
By the way, are you
Uh, secondly, uh, that's why you want to get a bleed because the bleed as you just saw
Uh, it does a little bit extra damage because you have that blood loss
buff
That's why a lot of people love doing the uchi katana or uchi ga
I can't pronounce it. Uh, what the name is and the rivers of blood because they're really good for bleed builds, but
I don't feel like doing reverse blood
I do love a good blood build though. Like I did do blood faith arcane. That was nice
The way it's supposed to go is you kill the tiny dragons and it kills the big one
Oh
I'm not going to do the gold feet until I get uh closer because it has a time limit on it
I
Guys remember taps the sign I have played the game before
You like frost frost is I never actually I never did anything with frost
Maybe they'll be the magic that I work I I do for intelligence
Shut up stop yelling
She's the mother of dragons why she liked this where's Daenerys? Oh, she put her arm up
Wait, no, I don't want to do that. I feel like she'll cross me. That's really cool though. I've never I've actually never seen her move this much
Sorry, I have to hit you in the fucking leg
There we go now we pop this bad boy
Okay
She currently goes too large so she could no longer either fly her babies bring her food. That's so sad
I
Hurry up, let them run out
Oh
Okay, we're so close
Forever bopping this lady only she would die. Hello. Where is it?
Fuck hurry up
Oh
Okay, bye
Any group, whoa, wow cool
I
Was a battle it's my first kill
I can whack you
Sick now I have a lot of fucking runes. Let's go. Um, so now
Yippie, I don't want you to shit. Uh, let's go
Yeah
Because now the fun starts, you know now the fun really fucking starts
Okay, I I need a plan
I need to plan and you think of what do I want for my build? So we're gonna sit here
Now time to kill I'm trying but
I'm thinking because we got like a hundred k runes we could you know farm
No, I need to get the mimics here next
I need to get the mimics here
Uh, because that's the only ash that I really care about I didn't really use anything. Um, let me
I'm gonna look up some weapons
Yes
Faith intelligence builds
You
Could get the sword of night in flame
Isn't that oh where's the sword of night in flame I totally forget
There's not actually it's it's really there's not a lot of fucking options for scaling with faith intelligence
So I might do like something else there's not a lot of
You can't really there's not a lot of weapons for a faith intelligence build
So
Yeah, I know I got it look like we're done
Okay
Again, I'm speed running I'm going there you want me to go I don't want to go full caster
I don't want to go full caster
I want to do more casting because I never
Like I'm I'm someone who I always just do like hack and slash the entire time like again
I told you I literally rolled with blood uh bloodhounds fang for the longest fucking time
Yeah, there's good options all around intelligence. Maybe I won't do faith
Like I'm debating because I now I'm tempted to do because I've done
A blood build now I'm tempted to do a frost intelligence build because frost seems cool
Although I remember I have had my put shit shit pushed in from an invader with the rock slingshit
So many options because I just want to know what I should put all these runes into you know
No
Not that I can't go farm runes I can always go farm runes. Hi reyna, welcome back
Oh reyna just hopped up on my desk and she pressed stuff. Oh reyna sweetheart. I okay. She's like I must snuggle with you mother now
Lend me a warmth
Hi reyna
Hi, I'm sorry. I didn't boop mean to boop you on the snoot. Oh, you want to give me a hug? Oh
I want to shit on my shoulder. Oh, you want to give me purrs
I've already done an arcane build
She wants to cave
Do
Furnace crest line since you're not an idiot like me that
Arches him on site first smack talking you. Yeah, I could do that
um
Oh, that sucks. I feel so bad for people who killed him right off the bat for that because that was a good place to farm
Thinking I'm thinking I'm thinking
What are some other uh faith in it have really good weapons in dlc true and that is the end game. We're only doing
this
Yeah, I don't don't spoil but that's good to know that's that is still really good to know because we this is the ultimate thing is
We're just trying to get a good build to get into the like as we're going into the dlc
Because i'm literally leveling a shit out of my stuff
and then
We're going to go straight for redawn and mog although I have to kill redawn anyways
so
And then we're just going to go straight for mog
Mog mog
Hmm
Mog is very weak to bleed yeah, because now i've tempted i'm like, you know
Bleed is just like, you know try to true. I do love a good bleed like blood bleed build
And i'm like do I go to kaolin do I farm for the scythe again?
Anyway, I just get that
Oh, because that's what I did in the faith the faith that I just bled, you know
You're gonna want to level up your flask too. Yeah. Yeah. No, I know I I do have to grab that stuff. I have to grab that stuff
You're right
Bleed is the meta I know but I hate that like everybody has a fucking blood build because it's easy, you know
I'm like, you know, do I do it because it's easy because I need easy
Comet azure is pretty good. Okay, I got to know
It's so funny. It's I don't know why but it's very ironic to me that mog is
weak against blood blood
So frostbite. Yeah
Think about that
Yeah, I was thinking about getting the uchi katana in the dungeon
And fuse it with cold
Oh, okay
Okay, you're on to something uchi katana
Get some cold
All right
In the moonville katana. Yeah
Yeah
Uh
The moonville katana
Is in kaolin in a dungeon, isn't it?
I'm just like really happy right now by the way, I just want to let everybody know that I'm happy because I'm just like
You can have like elvin ring stuff. Okay
Cool cool, uh, I'll just like search where that is on the map
I might copy your build so
Okay
If you progress ronnie's quest line is also the dark moon greatsword. That's true
I'm glad you're happy
I just love this game so much. I just love elvin ring
This their ability would never do I don't know really
Do you eat you have the elvin ring?
I told me after you yeah, uh, yes, I do it's I have it up on my phone. I read that is mega penis
I don't know why
The torch only builds
I'm not on android on iphone because it's easier for tracking for vtube vtubers
If honestly, I would consider searching to android if they did had some really good ar
stuff
Or whatever the light are whatever the fuck they use in iPhones
What is my least favorite build
Huh, what is my least favorite
I saw like the fists like people like
Are like the fucking pots on your hands
Bo's actually yeah bo suck dual shield
I've I've
I have enjoyed watching someone do a bow build only
It was fun to watch but not fun
It would be fun to do
Boomi are you pissing?
You just me out and then gone the litter box and piss did you just announce to everyone you're pissing?
Good job boomi good piss good job you pee like a little girl you squat
I'm also arts and dlc is super fun. I've heard that
Bo builds actually have good weapon now as well interesting
I'm so excited to get to the dlc portion. You guys have no idea, but again, I really want to
Um
And I won't lie to you. I'll probably pay play a little bit of this off stream
Uh just to get
To a good spot
Um and grind a little bit so you guys don't have to just see me grinding and just like farming and shit
Mother please must you announce my bathroom habits to everyone?
I know he just literally just like zoomied around the room afterwards
Now he's watching birds outside while he fucking tweaks out in the cat tree
The hell dude
Well, there he goes zoom in
Um
It's also super hard
Okay, what is the ideal level for the dlc is my question
That's what that is what I would like to know
A little level 170. Okay 150 150 ish. Okay. I can do that
Good to know good to know. Okay. So yeah, I definitely
I'll say 60 I'll do I'll do a cool 60 69 even
So I'll probably again, I might like grind stuff off stream
um
Especially because then I could just focus and just lock in and just be like
Um, but we're gonna play I'm obviously gonna keep playing until I get tired
Which will probably be like 1 a.m. So
Help you're locked in bros
150 minimum good to know good to know
Uh, you did it at 125 and it was hard as hair of last week
Boomi, what are you doing? You don't need to be up here. You just peed. I don't really appreciate this man
I'm gonna play with your little pouch
Boomi titties boomi titties boomi titties
He's like trying to walk and I'm just like poking his pouch
He has like
He has such a pronounced pouch
He looks like he has boobies especially because his nipples hang out boomi. Can you not paw at my tentacle?
He just like backed it. He's backed my tentacle
He's my tentacle to hold up my headphones. I still haven't used it yet because I haven't been feeling good
Maybe I'll use my tentacle later
For something other than headphone use
Hi Yashom
You're making rena nervous. Can you please leave? Thank you. Okay rena
rena doesn't really want anyone around her
besides like
Me and fia so she just doesn't like boomi
Because like she's fine with fia around her because she's injured
But if boomi comes near her, she's like very guarded. Did you want to get down rena? I can put you down
Let me move my microphone up the way and then I'll put you on the floor
There you go, man. Why don't you go lay down and have some water or something? Yeah
I'll let you miss John
She has a follow-up appointment in a couple weeks
I'm messing with the kitty foopa. Yeah
Watch a guy for a white mouse far. Yeah, that's true. I need to
Uh kill some fucking shit for that. Uh, I hate that part because I need to do I need to do his for the the farming thing
So I can kill that fucking
Yeah, so I can kill the fucking
But I also need to get a bow
Shit
I could
go
Into is it the limb grave?
Grave or whatever the fuck the dungeon underground
that
You get a nice bow from
Isn't there an urtary thing I can kill get a bow from too
Remember strong you got power level by chat giving your stacks the stacks of lords rooms
I don't think there's a reason to mention a pain to find people due to a level
interesting
And and if I do it now, it's probably going to be people who are newer players
Let's go buy a bow. Yeah, but I want a good bow
Yeah, that's in the first area. Yeah, that's right. I remember getting that before I might go back and do that now that I have a stone sword key
Yeah, usually I would just get it and get out. I just would read it and it'd be like hey, and then I would just leave
Serpent go bow, but the serpent I'd have to get what I have to get right card for that
Where's the serpent bow? No, you can kill right card with the serpent bow
I want to I want a nice bow. Oh, yeah, that's true. I can get the I can get redawn's bow
Why don't we just I'll just do that
I have done the I think when I played I did the AI invasions
Serpent bow was in the starting era. Where is the serpent bow?
I remember I have it. I had a certain bow. I forget how I got it though
Crossbow in the round table. That's a good point
Caleb cave easy to get to
Okay
Okay, which bow do you guys think would be best in redawn's bow serpent bow
the crossbow
I might I might do redawn's bow because he's on the way
He's like he's he's something I have to do anyways
I think I was bow last time too
I might just do the AI fight thingy. We'll have better range for the bird farm. Yeah, you're right
Yeah, see that's why I didn't want to just buy a bow. I think we're gonna do that
I think we're just gonna get redawn's bow
Um, then I gotta kill redawn
Get his bow mimic tear
Duvar is quest
Uh, yeah
I
My muppet is seven, bro. I'm gonna out the fuck does that mean?
Yeah, so with the rolling thing that would be like a whole puzzle I have to get to
Well, it would just be kind of straightforward if I just kill redawn
I'm very much human serpent
No, my butt is serving bro. I'm about to act up. What wait, what's wait though? Wait till what wait till I do this, huh?
Wait till I do this. What if I take these bad puppies off?
or if I
Take these puppies away
Now
My full power is unleashed
Now you see me in all my glory
Yeah
How's that make you feel?
Knowing you want to have relations with a puppet
Dirty dirty boy
or girl
Bible time
And she's uh, I remember I told her I was just like, oh, I don't think I'm gonna draw your things
I'm like, don't even bother don't even draw bother try the shabari. It would just be so annoying to do in this model
on this little guy
If I do collabs, I'm using this from now on for fuji tech. I'm using this from now on
Instead of my
um
Discord avatar
I want to use this
I'm now a puppet png youtuber
The limiters are off
I'm racist now
Ha ha
Basically my run to dlc godric rinola runan grab the miracle here did various quests farm rune levels and 60 fought moke
um
Why rinola and godric I'm I I'm interested
Uh
I bet
Rhinola so I can get
The respect yeah, yeah, yeah, that makes sense. Okay. Um, I probably will do that then I probably should
Also kill rinola
Godric for rune
Like leveling dex barf and dexterity is not the way in this game
um
Godric for his great rune
What is godric's gate rune? What does it do again? I forget
Do you not need to fight them? Oh, do I have to
Okay
Five times every start that's right
I went godric then moke with a 12 weapon only took me a hundred eighty five times
Okay
All right, so change of plans then we're mapping our way
Um
Godric the grafted
I remember I was like so thankful that like there's just like one person that I summoned in that just fucking wrecked him
with a comet
And I was like yo
Getting softcap so uh, but it's it's good for like
Just a basic thing though. I don't yeah, that's I think that's why they put him at the beginning of the game
Beware of any moke type enemies. What do you mean?
Excuse me
That's pretty solid. I get myself myself a seven out of ten for that. Maybe eight
If it was like oh, then I would have been better
Yeah, okay, that's all I agree. I agree with these I agree with these a little tisker
I love how me and strawnee both call it tisker because in my head I read it as tisker and she also calls it a tisker
We'll carry you until you get rid of dons. Yeah, precisely
Okay, I think I'm gonna level myself
intelligence
but like
What weapon do I get again? I've never done an intelligence build
I've done faith. I've done strength
I've done dexterity. I've done arcane
I've never really like messed with the magic aspect of Elden Ring minus like what's in faith
I never did any of the sorcery shit
I
Wish I did because it's like perfect for long range
Mommy, what are you doing?
Do you dexterity katana with frost or moonville? Okay. All right. Yeah, let's get let's get the let's get the moonville
Let's get the moonville
I 100 agree. Okay. Uh, where's the moonville?
It's in kaolin. It's in what you're gonna call it
I need to get the kaolin map
Uh, let's go over here and run to get the kaolin. Wait, there's a cliff, isn't there?
Oh, fuck me. I know there's like one here one there one there
I'm gonna start up here first actually
You
Tunnel for left that's right. I want to do frost because I think frost would be fun
And some of the gravity shit. Um, yeah, isn't it?
Is it right? Is this this isn't it right? This isn't where it is, right?
It's not here. It's like there's one like over here, right? I don't know am I tripping
It's this one
This is the one
Sometimes we need some rotten cotton
All the magic bug casters it's in the selly uh, it's in the selly the caves
Plates patiently for everybody to catch up and respond. I'm just gonna look
Oh
I'm debating whether or not to stay because I was gonna go over
Salem's house tomorrow to hang with her at her pool that she has at her house
For jill 4th of july, but I also want to keep an eye on arena
And I'll be stressed out if I go and if I do that, I'll probably just do a gorilla tomorrow of elden ring
And do some grocery shopping and shit
um
Sorry, I thought of that because she just texted me. She's like, you don't have to come over if you want to check on her
Okay
Well, me who are you talking to? I hear you making funny noises. I think rena just hissed at him
Uh
Okay, it is that tunnel. Okay, there is a grace right over here
This one here this one here. I really should just go up and around to be honest
I
Kind of need to find where all the maps are. I'll go get this map and I'll be I think I'll that'll do me a little bit better
Let's do that
Don't forget your milk and I know I need milk and eggs
I still have this in my hand
I didn't mean to do that
Um, okay, I have a lot of rooms so
What do you guys suggest that I should do because I can
Get to level 35
Which it's not as much as I thought it would be to be honest with you
I
Just all in vigor
All 37 a little bigger
Well, yeah, I know I'm supposed to do bigger, but what should I scale for everything else should I get everything at like 20?
I think I accidentally also put stuff like intelligence at 20
You
Next 30 needs to be 17 for the moon veil
Okay
Fine for more fp
I
Think I'm gonna do
Yeah, I'm not gonna worry about faith right now to be honest with you. I can always respect that later
I
Need 18 decks and 15 strength for a dawn bow
Really
Fuck
Ha
Will the serpents bow be better than what does the serpent bow scale with?
Because I was thinking about like because I think this looks good
I can do hand the bow. Okay, that's what I thought
Okay, but I'm not gonna worry about that then
Um
Sore seal a little farming
Okay, nice hand puppet
Hello, it's me your favorite puppet. It's me should be coming bum. I'm just glad to be here
In K-Lin what a lovely place
The rain's so nice. I love me a good thunderstorm
I think I was come on
Sore seal maybe not double damage sucks. Okay
She's lying. No one likes what I'm gonna build a family home in Kailin Kailin is the safest place on earth
I hope there's fan art of the puppet. I like being a puppet
Okay, I have one more level yet left. What should I put it into?
A mortar actually I might just put it into mind
Something for your mind mind mind mind
And I can get
Health
I think string is too man is too hand his bow actually strength checker bow is 15
Can
You also
Oh, I hope there's NSFW fan art puppet just like how I'm something someone said they're digging it. That'd be hilarious
Hmm
Where's the sore seal
I think I'm gonna I'm gonna settle with this for now
And I can always respect
I have 6,000 rooms though. I kind of want to make sure I can get one more level
Sore sales behind me what what do you mean?
It's just behind me behind me is it this no
I'm kidding because I never I never use the sore seal before
It's in the fort by the dragon what the fuck
In which direction
Bottom level it's below the dragon
So
Oh god
When you go up and then down so like co-across to the side then down there
Oh, it's in fort ferro, okay
The sore seal where you build you want us to howl agree. I don't feel like fighting millennia. No
Okay, then I'll go to the 50k dragon
I'll get that sore seal
Hi honey
I killed your mom you have a lot of cubes dude. Oh fuck
Again, I don't remember where names or things are
I'm saying a giant pumpkin distance. Oh, hey, my runes are still here
Hey, I got five runes. Let's go
Oh, hold on. Hold on. I should have gone this way instead
Every guy is supposed to go down rather than up
Oh torrents fly
I can't see
Raven it's your birthday. I can't swim
Okay
I don't know if we'll try to bang an elder than dragon. Uh
Oh this fucking oh fuck
Oh, I remember this, uh, where is this again in here? Is there a pumpkin head in here?
I kind of sworn there's
I'm thinking of the wrong forts because I could have sworn there was a golden
Thingamabob right over here. I guess I was wrong. I might be thinking of the wrong place
Oh, this is the one with the fucking harpies in it
Fuck me, um
Oh
Hold on
Let me just take a
Oh
Yeah, but like
Okay
You get a fucking lantern, that's why I need to fucking get
All right, you get up there good job
On the top where the gallows are that's right
I remember this and any other invisible dude
You jump down
Go around
Okay, you gotta watch the fucking rat jump across
Giant rat get down again
Oh
There it is dragon source, you know, all right
Um, it's kind of dark. Should I wait I'm gonna wait whole day. That's a good idea. Oh no shit
No torrent
I
See better because you guys don't fucking
It's gonna run past all the elderly. Yeah, no, I got this. I got this. I got this. I got this. I got this
I'm proud of myself
Kind of like don't want to hold this though. I just want to run. I feel like I'm lighter this way. All right, go
Fine
The fuck is below me
All right, all right, we're good. We're good. We go down, we go down, we don't down, we run, we run, we're running
We're jumping, we're going down, we're going down, we're going down, we're going down.
Oh.
Um.
Come on, I need to heal.
No, I gotta go back and get my runes.
I like, I spazzed out and I couldn't remember, I'm like, how do I heal?
I just got scared, I just got scared.
It's fine though, we're gonna go get it.
Also increases damage taken.
Why did I want this again?
I don't.
Uh.
How does this, this hasn't raised anything.
2.
Just don't get hit.
Oh, did I burp?
I didn't even notice.
Uh.
Alright.
Fuck it, we've all, I need my runes.
Can I get it from here?
I could just stand close to it and clip it through.
Um, alright.
Excuse me, excuse me ladies.
Fog down.
Nevermind.
What the fuck?
I could have sworn I heard somebody else talking in the chat and that threw me off.
I'm wondering if Azura came in and like, made a noise and ran away.
If so, I blame her for dying.
Did anybody else hear that?
Oh, hi Boomi.
How many did I lose on my runes?
How about I get like half of them back?
Cause I don't, I don't want to but I'm like one more level, you know?
That's why I kind of want them.
Oh yeah, they're gone, gone.
Okay, nevermind.
Boomi, I can't see past you.
I can't see past you.
I can't see past you, Boomi.
Boomi, please.
Can you fall me out?
Get off my desk.
Boomi, please.
What's going on here?
Oh, okay.
Miss Dart.
Oh, you're fucking huge ass.
Oh my god, it's so heavy.
I mean, now you're captured and you get kiss it.
Why are you so warm?
My thumbs.
Cause we don't mind being held like this.
What's that?
Usually you do mind being held like this.
Can you make a tissue?
Why are you trying to touch me, Boomi?
Why are you trying to treat us?
What's up with you?
What's with you?
Why are you trying to treat us?
How much space do you need?
Bye-bye.
You're also protecting me.
All right.
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
We're good.
Inventory.
We are switching to...
Free Spear.
Okay, this is the only thing I can essentially fucking use right now.
Can I...
Really unclip?
Let's go.
Can you use this on top of a horse?
I don't understand why you can't use stuff from a top of a horse.
That's like the only thing that's stupid of me.
Okay, time to...
go to that...
something on the way.
That's a big ass tower.
Equipment.
Yeah, sorry.
I'm a little stupid.
I'm a little slow.
All right.
Great.
Now I have to get to this fucking dungeon, too, after this.
Oh, hi.
It's the dragon.
Why are you so alive?
Because you died with your family,
which I'm so comfortable with.
Oh, there's all going to be little tangle monsters in here.
These trees are just dancing.
Oh, I forgot how many dragons are around here.
I thought it was going to be a little tangle,
a muncher monster.
Please do not get aggroed.
Okay.
Wait, am I going the wrong way?
I kind of did.
I thought I should go back.
Oh, God.
Wow, it's such a beautiful day out.
Perpetual sunset.
Love it.
Pretty nice.
Hi, dragons.
Please don't kill me, dragons.
Please, dragons.
I'm only level 35, dragons.
Oh.
I wish I could pick up items.
Torrent, can you pick it up for me?
Why is it called dragon mode?
I need K-Lid map.
Let's just follow this path.
I could go...
Because there's like, there's graces around.
Like, there's one over here, one over there,
and one over there.
I don't have a lot of graces active right now.
I definitely need some.
But, let's...
I don't think I'll be able to cross over here.
Yeah.
Let me try.
Okay.
Okay, alright.
There's a doggy.
Do you see it?
It's here.
I love this so I can see where I'm going.
Oh, don't die.
Good job.
Let's go, sweetie.
What the fuck up dog?
Oh, not this guy.
Hello.
Why is everything on fire here?
You guys have better things to do.
It's so hot.
My nose is itchy.
Okay, there should be Diagro.
This is good.
There's a grace right over here.
Perfect.
California is so beautiful.
Yeah, I know.
I mean, like...
Yeah.
I don't know what I was going to say.
I was reading something and I lost my train of thought.
Can I put this in a bite?
Can I put this little fucking stick in my other hands?
There are graces everywhere if you know where they are.
Wow, that is the most profound thing I've ever heard in my life.
Holy shit.
If you just look around you, there are so many graces.
You just have to know where they are.
No shit, bro.
Why is it still saying that my stuff is over there when it disappeared?
I don't...
Go away.
I don't need it.
Let's just die again so I don't have to...
I hate having the marker there because it's throwing me off.
What the fuck?
It's over here.
I'm actually getting bitched out by a Muppet.
That's funny.
Hi, lady.
Bye, lady.
I'm not showing you my fucking fingers.
You fucking freak.
I was just touching and smelling fingers.
You're all freaks.
You're all fucking stoked.
Fuck eat a puppy.
No, you don't want to do it.
I'm gonna go around the puppy.
Come on.
Torrent.
Oh, Torrent.
Oh, Torrent, please.
They said more health.
It's okay.
It's all right.
I want that.
Oh, nothing.
There's people on fire.
Everybody's just on fire.
I'm so sick of it.
Beautiful California whistle.
I like when things die and just give me rooms.
That's my favorite.
Okay.
Oh, fuck it.
Can you please stop agroing?
I don't want to pick up these rooms.
Hello, little slug thing.
Oh, there's lava.
Everyone, did I miss?
Thank you, good.
Bye, little sluggies.
Okay.
It's right around here.
I fork or where the opening is.
And I can't, oh, I can't open the map.
It's like right here.
Tell me your wisdom.
That's not helpful.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, because I am.
I can show you the world.
There it is.
Shining, shimmering, kaolin.
Tell me, harem, did you ever thought
you could be on a magic carpet ride?
A whole new floor.
A dazzling brothel you never knew.
And when you're way up here,
you're super queer.
Sorry.
Now I'm in a heart with you.
Now I'm in a whole new heart.
Unbelievable tits.
I wonder where he's going.
Oh, I meant to do this.
Hey.
I thought there was going to be like a platform below.
Well, how many deaths am I at?
Like five?
That's actually pretty good.
All right, let's let's try that again.
Oh, fuck.
I have to go all over there.
Hi, lady.
Bye, lady.
Fucking freak.
Okay.
Wait, I know there's a closer one.
Let me just make sure.
It's over here, I believe.
I might just run around the path and get to that one.
Just so it'll be easier for me to go across, I think.
I don't know, actually.
Well, actually, let me go back to where I was and then we'll try it.
Okay, don't fuck with the dog and the bird.
I didn't see the bird up there before for whatever fucking reason.
Hi puppies.
Oh, hello puppies.
Hi puppy.
I love puppy.
I love donkeys so much, puppy.
What are y'all doing over here?
Just forcing a poor crab to, oh, this is what's happening.
Oh yeah, give me all of the, no.
I just wanted to watch you guys fight.
What's my job, bro?
Why don't you focus on the fucking crab killing your ass in the dog?
Yeah, well, how about that?
Yeah, the dog's fucking bopping your asses.
Holy shit, they're killing him.
They just killed that crab together.
Oh god, oh, I'm next, aren't I?
I should probably leave.
I think that's a good idea.
I think leaving is a great idea.
Actually, I do have to go back around.
Yeah, they're distracted.
Fine, they're distracted.
Why don't you guys go fight the dog?
I kind of wish their dogs would come over here and just kill these dudes.
Surprise, it was I.
It was me.
Oh yeah, no, I wouldn't be able to do that.
There's no point because, yeah, that wouldn't work out.
So I guess it's like this.
Why is that?
Oh, it's so red.
I'm like, I thought there was like a gap there.
Hi, hello, let me just get down.
Oh, um, well, how am I supposed to get down from there?
He pushed me off.
I'm playing this game for the first time.
I'm mad at being silly.
It's okay, birds aren't even real.
You know what?
You're real for saying that.
I agree with you wholeheartedly.
Anyways, torrent, wait.
Okay, that's still there.
Fuck.
Oh my god, Boomi, what the fuck are you doing behind me?
You're freaking me out.
You're making weird noises and you're scaring me.
I thought it was somebody else.
My door locked.
You can't tell.
Door is locked.
Okay, we're good.
I'm scared.
I'm notorious and some of you guys know that I just leave my door locked.
I'm not sure I leave to go do something.
Puppies are gonna fall on me.
It's fine, it's all good.
I'm gonna lead them to the little crabby.
He's having a little spat.
Hi, hello, hey.
Ow, how the fuck did you get me?
Where the fuck did that dog come from?
How do I get down?
Hello?
Hi.
This kid is missing us, so turn me into Muppet.
I'm a fucking Muppet, bro.
Get Muppet.
Don't you want to Muppet me?
Don't you want to have your way with this little Muppet?
A little soft Muppet body?
I have just one giant hole just for you.
First time catching me live?
This is awkward.
Third time's the charm, surely.
How do I get down?
I don't see a ladder.
Do you guys have any wisdom?
Touch bloodstain.
What about you?
Okay, you just kind of backed him and then he killed you?
All right.
Get my sneak.
Okay, I can get him.
I don't know why I didn't get him.
Whoa, never mind.
Never mind.
Why the fuck are you so strong for no fucking reason?
Why are you guys looking at each other like that?
Were they going to kiss afterwards?
I think they were going to kiss afterwards.
It was only like 300.
It doesn't matter.
It was literally dropping the bucket.
Where am I going?
I'm a fucking idiot.
All this just to get into the freaking dungeon.
I've never been in this one.
I've never been in this cave before.
I never went for the Moonville Katana.
Boomi, why do you have the zoomies right now?
See, your food's going off.
Oh, it's a dog.
Not a crab.
Okay, hold on.
Let me just look for a moment.
Okay, let us...
Let me point to above my head.
Yes, I've played the game before.
I know Kailit is hard.
You don't have to tell me, sweetheart.
Katana.
If it's two minutes and less...
Oh, no, you talk.
I have to mute you now.
All right.
Cool, cool, cool.
Yes.
What the fuck?
Oh, he went a different way than I did.
That's why.
You...
Wait, Heidi.
Okay, you get down there.
Okay, all right, all right, all right.
I got you, I got you.
All I care about is how to get past these guys
and know where to land.
I don't care about anything else.
Right here.
That's where the platform is.
Are you going to jump down?
Fucking bitches.
Oh, there's fire.
What?
Where did the fire come from?
Where's...
Where's the fire come from?
Where did that fire...
Oh, my God.
Where did the fire come from?
Oh, there's a grease down there.
Sick.
Oh, no, I'm not going to make it.
Oh, I made it.
I don't know where the grease down here.
There's both clean pots up.
Let's take a...
Pop a squat.
We're so back.
Wait, I need to look up the guide again.
I'm going to go back.
I'm going back.
Okay.
Got it.
Let's go.
I'm kind of forget...
Open.
Oh, wow, it's this.
Oh.
What the hell?
What are you doing here?
Is that Alexander?
How are you?
How did he...
How the fuck?
How the fuck did he get there?
Where the fuck did this guy come from?
Well, that's convenient.
Yeah, yeah.
What are you doing here, bro?
That thing.
Why don't I ever remember meeting you here?
I never was in this dungeon.
Is this where you can meet him?
Where a festival is being held.
Until I was stumped by that dead end.
My love, I have returned from doing the dishes.
I'm so proud of you, sweetheart.
Alright, interesting.
I like how it's a festival just to kill somebody.
Yeah, it's a milling stone, boy.
I have to get so many fucking...
Oh, shit.
Alright.
This is just the exit.
So, let me go...
Fuck my life up with this boss.
I'm gonna fucking suck.
This is gonna take me so long.
He basically just came as a passage.
Oh, it's a magma worm.
This doesn't do the damage.
This is gonna take a while.
Why is it so narrow?
Oh, I didn't push that.
I didn't push this.
Oh, no.
I must stop.
Summon the ash.
Yeah, actually, yeah.
That would take the aggro off of me for a little...
I like how he just falls back asleep.
Yeah, maybe I should summon the ash.
You're still here, bro.
What's going on?
I don't know.
You're still here, bro.
What's going on?
Like you said, you were leaving.
What's the sigma?
I didn't even equip the fucking ashes.
It doesn't matter.
I don't know.
Yeah, I was thinking about the meteorite staff
and the rock sling as well.
I was thinking about that.
Okay.
My fucking butt hurts.
Raina, I'm sorry, but you can't be on my lap right now, sweetie.
Mommy's trying to beat a boss in Elden Ring.
She just flicked her tail in annoyance.
Should I do the wolves or the jellyfish?
Which is more effective.
Excuse me.
Jellyfish?
You think?
Raina, where are you?
Yeah, you're right, you're right.
I'm not pressing this button.
All right, puppy dog.
Alexander, you want to fucking help me?
You're just going to stand around and be a jar.
All right.
Sick of him.
I'm going to poke his ass.
No, Raina, are you serious?
I can't.
Raina, please.
Raina,INA!
Raina, space, sleep.
All right, here I was locked on.
Okay, arena sweep.
Why could I lock on?
Hello?
Oh.
Whoo!
Hello?
Oh.
Woo-hoo!
Ow.
Get him!
Sick of him!
I'm going to die.
Get him!
Actually, you know what I should do?
I should actually be using a two-handed morning star.
Cuz...
I don't know, he's dead.
He's only going to do the bleed.
Nope, I didn't mean to do that.
Peace.
This is why bleed is good.
Ow.
That was very nice.
That was very cash money in here.
Ow, Jesus.
Fuck.
What was that?
I see a little boost on that thing.
I use a sword.
You're a lizard.
You don't deserve a sword.
Ow!
Yeah, not even like a third.
Done.
You're not even like near the lava, I don't know what you're saying.
Wait, huh?
Oh, he just a little stompy-stomp.
And I guess so many attempts this will take.
Jesus Christ, you guys think this will take 30 attempts for me?
Oh my God.
You're probably right.
Um...
Oh, I had to press this.
Get him.
No, Jellyfish, get out the way.
How did he already fucking kill him with one hit?
That's not nice.
That's not fair to him.
I don't know.
I'm just going in a circle.
There's a wall there, baby.
Oh, well, sometimes the camera law fucks me.
He's going to stop around in there, then?
Oh, bro.
They're just gathered, bro.
I'm going to die.
I'm stuck in lava.
Come on.
I can't tell what's happening.
Ranged Magic is king.
Amazing that my Glenstone did like fucking nothing.
Does...
Let me just...
I'll try it, but I don't...
I wasn't really doing anything to him.
I wanted to do the bleed,
because then I would get at least a little bit of bleed damage every so hits.
Okay.
Wow, this is doing so much damage.
I'm so talented.
I...
I don't even...
Lava boy over here.
Lava girl.
I'm only a lava boy.
I actually don't think I might lock on,
because I'm just getting stuck with the fucking camera.
Alright, you're cheeky.
Alright, you're fucking cheeky.
I need to heal.
Okay.
Give me your ass.
Oh, why?
Why, cats?
Why?
I'm going to...
Oh my fucking god, Vini.
I swear to fucking god.
Get out of the fucking way.
I was doing better.
Why?
Why did you do that?
Why are you so cute?
I love you.
You smell like food.
Did you just eat?
Cat debuff might be a factor.
Yes, because my cats like to hop up on my desk
and get in front of my display.
Zzz.
And now Boomi's about to take a shit.
They hate me.
My cats hate me.
Um, yeah, no.
Fuck the fucking glint stone.
No, that's not going to work out.
I don't know why I sat down, but it's fine.
Boomi, stop sending me my feet.
It's unnecessary.
Stop, bro.
Stop, stop.
Can you leave my feet alone?
Can you leave that alone?
Thank you.
My brother in Christ.
Please.
Hi, Fiya.
Hi, little girl.
You look so cute over there.
I can't look out from you because you're behaving.
What are you going to go ahead for?
Are you going to stick yourself to my chair again?
Feetsies.
Fiya really likes feetsies.
Sometimes I call her Fida.
She likes fart.
I'm ready to fuck people up.
Ah.
Justice for Boomi.
I'm going the wrong way.
Okay, he doesn't seem to care.
Sorry.
I think the wolves will actually be a little bit easier because I feel like they can move
around a lot faster.
I don't know what I got in my eye yesterday, but I think I cut the inside of my eyelid.
And it is so painful.
Or I got bleach in my eye because I was cleaning stuff.
So who knows?
I don't know.
I don't know if bleach does that.
It really hurt when I tried to wash it out.
I'm going to kill my fillet just right off the rip, bro.
You're going to kill me right off the rip, bro.
I can't see.
The room is so small.
This might take more than 30 tries, boys.
My eye's fine.
I can see out of it.
It just hurts.
And then I flipped my eyelid inside out and it was super fucking red because it felt like
I had a cut in there.
I'm like, did a fucking eyelash slice me and got in my eye or whatever?
I don't...
Okay, I'm going to try it with the wolves instead.
Because I think with the wolves, they'll be able to run around and kind of...
Let's try it.
Open the room.
Dumbass dogs.
Why are you going in the fucking lava?
I don't think I was healing when that happened.
Haha!
On guard.
Chicken.
Go on.
Uh, guys...
I don't know if I'm going to get this.
It's hot in the fucking camera.
I don't know.
I know!
Alzeir just hears me dying in the next room.
He's like, I'll see you there!
I'll see you at the festival!
And then just fucking perish in the next room 50 times.
You'd also think like he'd be gone, like once you...
Like, I don't get that.
I don't know why this bleed isn't fucking working right now.
Is the worm resistant to bleed?
What the fuck?
I swear my hip-hop isn't that big.
It doesn't matter anymore.
I'm still alive?!
What?!
I thought I was dead!
I just, like, stopped moving!
Okay, fuck the camera.
Fuck the cameras.
Cut the cameras!
I can't even hit you.
No!
Oh, I tried to roll out of the way, but I wasn't close enough.
I don't worry, Mr. Baby Dragon.
If you take too long, we'll break between the hits.
Yeah, you're right, you're right, you're right.
You are right.
That would be correct.
How far did I get first play through?
I won!
I beat the game!
I got the frenzy flame ending!
I'm sorry.
But thank you for the tip.
I know, I got distracted.
Oh, no!
No, my butt!
It's got a headache from that.
You know, for the longest time,
I didn't know Blive had, like, an actual wolf head.
I thought...
I thought I was just wearing a mask the entire time.
I am...
getting out of the fucking way and it's not working.
I got all the damage I did with my Blive, Blive.
Like that.
Whee!
Oh, you like that?
Right in the fucking eye, suck it in it.
I'll leave you with a kiss.
Yeah, you get that.
This sheebie Muppet needs to violently shake when speaking.
Wait, hold up.
I got you.
Hi, I'm Sheebie.
What's up?
I'm a Muppet.
Fuck your mom.
Um...
Tomo is...
We're gonna make me, like, my arms move, too.
Like, that I, like, shrug my arms.
What the fuck?
That noise.
Oh, it's just sleeping.
That's why it's making a lot of sleeping noise.
And it just wasn't working out.
And I thought it wasn't working out,
so she had already drawn on the layer,
and she was like, ah fuck,
and I was like, oh, it's fine.
Like, I just, like, ring a box.
Sick' cm, boys.
Sick' mm.
Get his ass!
Got his ass!
Yeah!
Fuck' em up!
I hit his belly.
Fuck' em up, fuck' em up!
I'm staying solid...
I'm staying solid.
I'm solid.
Get out of the way...
Get out of the way.
Out of the way...
Out of the way, I'm dead.
It's fine.
We're good.
the fourth of the way there.
Maybe a fifth?
That was pretty cool.
You so cute and funny.
You think I'm cute and funny?
Yeah, that's so nice of you.
Oh my God.
He thinks I'm cute and funny.
I don't know why I have a valid girl accent
when I'm talking like this.
This isn't even my cute and funny voice, is it?
Ah, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Um.
Hmm.
Ha.
There must be a better way.
I know I can beat this demon.
I just have to believe in myself.
Oh, fuck it.
Fuck it.
He sounded like God Earth.
Ow.
Oh, fuck him out.
Don't roll into the fucking lava, Shibi.
Don't roll into the fucking lava.
Oh my God, please.
Oh my God, no.
You have me in a fucking corner, bro.
Oh, fuck your mother.
Fuck your mother so hard.
I hate it here.
Darn stream for Magma Worm.
I think I need a snacky.
What is this?
I don't even know what this is.
Adorable cracker.
That's what it says.
That's what my mom called me when I was younger.
Okay.
He smells so bad.
I'm not eating this.
Nevermind.
That smells horrible.
What is this?
Another fucking butter cookie?
Oh, it's a rice cookie, I think.
Rice cracker.
Yup.
That's a rice cracker.
I don't think I like the taste of that.
They sound like God or some sort of neutron when they barf.
Get up puppies.
No.
Guys, I don't think I want to be the...
Guys, I don't think I want to read them.
I'm gonna be here a bit.
Move up.
I'm gonna help her.
I hate that you look like you're made of shit.
At least get to the 30 for the bet.
Bring the tummy, bring the tummy, bring the tummy, hold on.
Get him, don't get him.
Mmmmm!
Your beans wouldn't be so much better.
Why am I doing this?
Hello? I didn't mean to press that.
get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get
out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out,
get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out,
get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out,
get out, get out,
get out, get out, get out, get out, get out,
get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out,
get out, get out,
get out,
scratch my eye,
my hands are sweating,
knees, weeks,
arms to getty,
his vomit on his sweater already,
who wants to getty,
No, I don't think so.
I am a gamer, but I am not a good gamer.
You are my candy, and I'm stuck on the camera lock.
Get his leg, get his fucking leg, get his fucking leg, get his ass, get his ass, get his leg.
No, jellyfish, get out of the fucking way!
Jellyfish!
Jellyfish, no!
No!
I already knew that was a bad one.
The restaurant was good, the couple runs ago was good.
I know jellyfish did take that entire fucking hit, he's just like, I'll eat this.
I'll eat this and spit it back out of your face in the form of poison.
Black girl, his boy is not, maybe any like that battle music.
Maybe any like that black stripes, sorry white stripes.
The black stripes.
Yeah!
Stepping down, stepping down, kicking down, kicking down, kicking down.
Your fucking bootyhole, Imma poke your fucking bootyhole.
Oh
What the fuck just happened the camera just
That's a spacey meatball
Don't die jellyfish
I didn't know I could pass us across the session
Get his ass, get his ass, get his ass
You can't see me
Yeah
I
Was stuck I was stuck. I was stuck. I was stuck. I was stuck. I was stuck this is the run
This is the run. I was fucking stuck
I got stuck because the stupid fucking camera lock sometimes I hate locking on because the camera fucks me, bro
I swear to God
It's fine. It's fine. Now, you know, we know what we're doing now, you know, I hope I don't have neighbors
My neighbors don't hear me just screaming at the top of my fucking lungs. I don't think I don't think I have a neighbor below me anymore
I think they moved out
Or
They they still live there, but
This is what I mean, bro, what is this?
As you guys can see my face
My muppety angry expression
Cameraman up for real though
Hands are sweaty he's vomit on a sweater already
Thank you, Namas
What just call me to calm down
I'm squinting you can't tell I'm gonna ignore that
I can't heard you talking to smack it. Oh me. Are you meowing?
Everybody good
Are you know sleeping nicely on a chair assuming everybody's fine
You're a pain behind those muppety eyes
The Muppet really pushes the point
Yo, he already get killing myself
I'm punching you. I'm punching you your dick. How could you you killed my guy?
Where did my I don't know where my sword went
That's a fuck as I laugh bro the hell all right
Fuck you Alexander
Just fucking just sit in there doing fuck all swear to God
Oh
Not my baby, no
Game is so loud, holy shit
I
She we got to go refueled on dr. Pepper. Oh, thank you
Dr. Pepper would be good right about now actually I can use Dr. Pepper. I
Know they got some spicy hot to
It's all right, I got some spicy hot to look it's called jellyfish poison
Okay, I need to not summon him right at the beginning I keep saying that and I keep fucking doing some stupid. Oh
I time that
Oh, it's like hair. What's up with that? Why do you have hair on the edge of your sword?
Why does a giant lizard have a sword in the first place? How did you get the sword?
Who made you the sword? It looks like it was made of the tail of your brethren. I don't know if I like that
You know, I don't if I like that. That's kind of fucked up
You're the dragon you're right you're right. All right, I'm gonna beat the first attack
I
Needling
Okay, it's okay. It's okay. It's okay. It's ass
Yes
That's they run the front
We're going away how did that hit me
Jump
We poke his ass
other ass
Let me die
What the hell bro
Kind of like give me a one hit
That's fine, that's fine. Let me wipe my hands
Fuck you Alexander. Yeah, fuck you. You know, you know
Wondering if I should go back for the blood blood thing
I
Mean I was hoping you wouldn't notice me
Keep rolling rolling rolling walking rollin rollin rollin rollin come on
Get out of the way
I
Amazing actually I just but like
like 50 different bosses. I already beat the game twice. We're on New Game Plus 3 right now.
It's pretty sick. It's pretty awesome. Everybody's kind of amazed by my skills.
Oh, no. Jellyfish.
Oh, I'm killing my jellyfish too soon because when the jellyfish gets back into the corner,
I'm fucked. I'm dead. I don't know what number are we at. I don't know if I should even bother
with this anymore. Like I'm determined to, but I just don't think realistically I'm not high enough
level and I'm not enough skilled even if I was this level.
Oh, no. Why does he always attack when I summon him?
Because I need him to stack the lava. I don't want him to go back into the corner.
I mean, I'll stack the lava, stack the poison.
When can you fucking jump like that? I have not seen you do this fucking move, bitch.
You four? How dare you?
You don't get to whip around like that.
I can't use that pretty much either.
You done yet?
Come on, bro. You're not just killing me.
This is not a good run. I'm pressing the, like, oh.
Why don't you let me do a paneling for us?
Or do you be a dagger to help with the damage? Maybe.
I'm kind of determined.
Downloading the move set. Locking in.
It's all right. Back it up. Back it up.
Get up. Jump. Jump. Get out of here. Back up. Back up. Pull it back. It's fine.
We're good. Do a little ding-ling.
Yes. Yes.
It's all right.
Isn't there like supposed to be like a super thing I can do?
Like in his eye? I did try like that so many times.
I totally fucking jumped over that.
What? What? What, bitch? What are you gonna do? What are you gonna do, bitch?
You're fucking the ass again. You're fucking the ass again.
Leave my jellyfish alone. He's just a little boy. My voice is cracking.
I'm in the eye. I gotta hit the glowy eye. I'm trying to hit the glowy eye.
I'm trying to. Oh no, you took him out.
No.
Oh, no.
All the wrong direction.
I'm trying to get him to charge.
What? He didn't even hit me with anything. He just walked up to me and I was supposed to hurt me.
Oh my god, I pressed the wrong button.
I don't remember what I just want to even have a quick blast.
No, no, no. I was hoping. Oh no, I'm stuck. I'm stuck.
Oh, the poison was doing work. The poison is doing work. It's but it's fine.
The more the closer and the closer I get to know I can do it just by brute forcing it.
Okay, but first, how the fuck do I poke him in the eye to get the extra damage?
I'm doing the charged heavy attack. It's not doing anything. I'm doing left trigger.
I have to light attack him.
Okay, I have to let R1 no charge.
Okay, okay, I'm okay. And I was screwed myself over by that because I didn't just not fucking paying attention.
I'm gonna do this right off the back early pop.
Oh, we got out of the way first.
Damn.
Did he already kill him? How the fuck?
I dodged that. Okay.
Yeah.
That doesn't even do a lot.
Oh, okay.
I have a little temper tantrum over here, bud.
Here, spin around. Oh, yeah, I saw that coming. I saw that spin coming.
I love a forgetful madam. That was better, though. If I can keep jellyfish alive to get that poison,
um, that I think I think I'm good. I think I'm good. I don't know how he died so fast.
If I get up real close to him, right off the river. No. No, be free.
I ate that for you.
Why are you throwing it at your time?
I can't really tell what's going on here. I don't know how to approach this situation.
I kind of, he's already fucking, he's doing this too fast.
Like, I'm kind of confused. He's like doing the magma thing a little bit too fast right off the rip.
And when he does that, it's a bad run.
You know? What the fuck am I kicking? Where did my fucking thing go?
I'm fucking kicking his ass. Fuckin' punch you. Fuckin' duff your ass. Fuckin' fuck you.
Yeah, why is he spamming lava? I don't know if that's fair to you yet.
Uh, well, no, I just started.
I'm getting warm. I'm like cold and warm at the same time.
Fuck you. Fuck you for that. Yeah, she could be helping me. Could be helping me, but no.
Okay, I'm gonna bait him. I'm gonna bait him. I'm gonna masturbate him. I'm gonna masturbate his ass.
No. No, you're supposed to attack me, you fuck. Get his ass. Get his ass.
Oh, no. I'm on fire. I'm on fire.
Okay.
Go.
I definitely dodge that, but go off this.
Stab his ass. Stab his ass. Stab his ass. Get stabbed. Die.
Alright, press a normal button.
There we go, there's that poison buildup.
He did well, he did well.
Fuck, I'm stuck, I'm rolling for all my life.
Stop, are you gonna stop?
I'm gonna raise up.
I can't let Jellyfish have that defeat.
Where am I?
Damn.
Damn, that sucked.
I thought that was a good run.
That was good, I like that, I'm proud of myself.
Thank you guys.
Kinda looks like a bearded dragon with a sword, that's what everybody else was saying.
How about you, I see my Jellyfish, he's really neat, he's just a little guy.
Oh he's almost gonna be dead already, this is a bad run, I'm gonna kill myself.
This is a bad run.
The moment I know that he is too low health because this dude magma runs him into the fucking ground, it's not a good run.
I need that poison to build and it's not building.
If the poison builds and I get the combos, then yeah.
It's gotta be 20, it probably is 20.
I'm not gonna get it in 30, I'm not gonna get it in 30.
I was pretty confident it was.
Yeah, eyes on me buddy, eyes on me.
Why do I have this equipped?
Why?
Give me the leg, that's what I wanted.
Oh no, that's fine, that's fine.
Jellyfish bro you gotta move, oh my god.
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
I legit almost just threw my controller there.
That's what, I literally almost spiked my fucking controller at that one.
Raina no.
Raina mama's getting angry, she probably senses my anger, she's like I will calm you down.
You're doing great sweetie, I'm determined.
Taking off my fucking clothes, sweating.
You're doing so well but I'm not, why are you guys lying to me?
What the fuck, I didn't know there was lava there.
You think cause it's floating that it wouldn't really be affected by this shit, but it does.
You think that because it's floating the lava wouldn't really touch it, but it does.
It killed me.
I'm tempted to try to get the, I think I'm gonna try to get, actually no I'll stop trying
then we can hit the third when we hit 30 else.
I'll go and try to see if I get the Bloodhounds Fang so I can fuck this dude up so I can get the Moon Veal.
See right off the rip I know it's a bad run when he does this immediately.
I think it's because of my proximity to him.
It triggers it.
Why?
Since when do you do that?
You've done that twice and it doesn't make any sense to me.
He's styling on me now.
I know he's stuck his little sword in his mouth and was like, you bet he dooduh.
Hello?
We're both gonna eat that actually.
I'm actually might gonna die.
It's fine.
It doesn't matter.
I would have died anyways if I got the right one or not.
Yeah, you get him Jellyfish.
Nine damage.
That's a lot of damage.
We're getting there.
I don't know about that.
Sorry, I'm tired.
I don't know, I had this fucking clip too.
Immediately when I summon that he...
Okay, good.
That's fine.
I would rather...
No, don't kill him.
Turn around.
Turn around to me.
Reina, this is not the time.
I love you, but stop.
Oh, there you go.
You're gonna kill me here, Reina.
I can't even see my stats.
She's just rubbing against my plant.
I don't know.
Reina.
Reina, please.
I love you so much.
No idea, but...
I'm doing stuff right now.
I snuggle with you all morning.
What's up?
You rumbling?
Are you trying to calm me down because I'm getting aggravated?
Are you trying to calm me, Reina?
You sense my...
You sense my stress.
Sometimes you just need a cat hug.
Reina actually is very much in tune to my emotions.
If I am very upset, she will immediately...
I think that's why she was kind of stuck to me this, like, yesterday.
It's because, like, since I was sick, she was...
I would, like, take a nap, and she was there, and I'd wake up, she was there.
If I was doing anything, she would just be there.
She's my baby girl.
Okay.
You wanna dance with the devil?
Let's dance.
What is this attack?
He already killed my jellyfish.
I should just leave.
Can I leave? Can I go?
We just...
It's no fair.
I don't like it here.
Let me go through the pee fog.
Reina, is your familiar?
Oh, yes, of course.
Actually, her sister was, like, my familiar.
She'd always sit with me.
Her sister, Solea, was sit with me when I would tear out cards.
Her sister died, uh, about, like, three years ago?
Yeah, four.
Sweet. She was a seal point same as Cat.
Her name was Solea. She was adorable.
I liked her, because she was, like, Reina's, like, clearly my cat,
but Solea was, like, everybody's cat in my family.
Why am I not dancing?
I'm, like, trying to get to its...
Oh, the fire got me.
It was actually going fine, because the jellyfish was doing okay.
Might have been a good run if I didn't get knocked into the fire.
There was a second Reina?
Yeah, her sister.
Her sister reminds me a lot of Fia and Boomi,
and I like to think that she lives on in them with very similar personalities.
It's quite funny.
Okay, if I do him over here, he doesn't seem to get...
I'm locked in.
I don't know what you're spitting at, girl.
Get out of the way, jellyfish.
I don't know why you're standing there.
Can you dodge, jellyfish?
Oh, I can't hit. That's for sure.
I rolled. I pressed roll, but I was locked in.
I'm stabbing you, the gluay guy, sort of dog.
That gives him a little bit of time to build that.
Poisoned build, so we're fine.
That's what I wanted. Maybe I should just pay back and let the poison build.
He done? Like, what is...?
Oh, my God.
Computer is struggling right now.
What is this? Why do you keep spamming the same fucking attack, dude?
Oh, my God, I'm stuck.
I don't understand that.
I'm going to spam attack, you can spam attack, I want that.
I'm going to attempt to just run in circles and let the fucking poison get him.
Kind of wishing I had the dragon's breath.
Sometimes it just locks onto his head and I'm kind of frustrated by that.
Oh, my God.
Locked in.
Oh, I thought I jumped out of the way.
That's the fucking karma, dude.
You see it messing up my attacks because I try to lock on, but it just...
Yeah.
I don't...
It's so weird.
I hate that I'm angled.
I don't like that the point just always attacks his head.
I'm trying to go for his leg and then it just pulls him.
It pulls it and it makes it go for his head.
Yeah, S-Talk has an issue.
I never really use a piercing weapon for that reason.
Come over here, come over here.
No, no, no, no, no.
You better come over fucking here, bro.
You better fucking come over here.
Great, how am I supposed to get to a fucking eye like this, huh?
Oh, wow, that's fucking great, isn't it?
I love that for me.
I love that so much for me.
Better do it again.
I better fucking do it again, I swear to God.
That's so dumb.
Did you see that?
How the fuck am I supposed to get to the spot if it's the fucking flames right in the way, dude?
Oh, my fucking god, bro.
Holy shit.
I'm enthusiastic, she viewers me.
She's going to pull the fucking flames immediately, immediately, immediately when I summon.
You hear this?
It's me gripping the fucking of my controller right now.
There's a muffin, it's really funny.
I'm going to kill him for you.
No, where's the fun in that?
Where's the fun in that?
I don't want anybody doing anything for me unless they ask.
I want to do this for myself because I'm going to feel so fucking good, so full of dopamine after I finish this.
Because I'm going to beat him.
I'm going to beat him.
It's not worth it, it's not worth it to you, it's worth it to me.
This is just, I'm sorry, I'm determined, this is how I game.
When I'm determined, I want to beat, I'll see something through.
And you know, I wanted to get to 30.
I think I'm at, I don't know if I'm at 30.
Let me know how many times have I died.
Because if I'm at 30, I'm going to go try to get the bloodhounds back because I want the moon veil.
I'm at 46, legit.
Okay, I'll do one more run.
And then I'm going to go, I'm going to do something else.
Uh, what am I doing?
Alright.
I love that.
Oh, oh, you're a little saucy boy, aren't you, with your little dive?
Aren't you cute.
I'm going to do it again.
Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Huh.
We're just opening over here.
There's always like a little opening left behind.
What is the worm weak against, by the way?
I should have, I should have fucking figured that out.
Right on cue.
It's fine.
I'm always in fire, I can't get him.
He's like that, oh, he's dog piling my fucking dude.
Yeah, like I can't.
Okay.
Can I stop aiming at his fucking head?
Oh, it's so dumb.
I love how differently you and strong you play this game.
What do you mean?
She really gets as many times as her age.
No, wait, I need to read what the fuck you guys are saying.
I'm in solar style.
This box is versus everything.
You're right, I think I remember, I think I remember that.
Excuse me.
I'm 56, guys.
I'm 56, you guys know this.
That was weak.
I keep sitting down like it's fucking Liza P and that I don't need that.
Oh, I'm in the fucking, no.
Oh, I have to be.
I can't teleport out.
I have to walk out.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
I wanted to play for longer, but I can feel myself getting a migraine.
I forget, where was that jail?
Oh my god, where was it?
I don't know.
I totally forgot it's over here.
Oh, you don't sound like you're 56.
Yeah, I'm 56, bro.
I'm pretty old.
You don't like your hag?
I'm like, yeah, I'm a fucking hag.
Uh...
Sorry to put Rena on the floor again because she's...
She's trying to jump up on me.
I wish I could see.
How many markers did I have?
Okay, just that one.
Have Blive help?
No, I don't need Blive help.
I will ask for help when I want it.
Ugh, I'm going to start ignoring people if they're like,
let me help or you should do this to do it.
I'm doing it by myself the way I want to do it.
If I need help, I will ask.
It's that simple.
I'm always in my prime, indeed.
Maybe I can use a jellyfish on this, dude.
Oh, I'm going to need to do that.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, I'm pressing breathe.
Come on, my nose is itchy.
My nose is itchy, please.
Let me carry you, Queen. No more.
I think that's what I said.
He got that dog in him.
What does it count?
It she does.
I don't get it sleeping.
So none of these count, Raina.
Please stop.
Why don't you go lay down, Raina?
I don't want to have to put you in the crate.
You're moving around too much.
I don't want you reopening your little thing in the water.
That's a spry lady at 14.
I felt like I was going to do something before this.
Are they trying to give me an intervention?
That's stupid.
I can't use a summoning thing for this.
Can I? No.
Alright.
Me and you, Darwin.
Oh, shit.
Well, this is awkward.
I just wanted to be friends.
I heard you had that dog in you,
and I was just wondering if you
wanted to put that dog in me too.
What the fuck am I saying, bro?
I can't hit you. You're too fast.
I think I had blood loss.
Sheebie! Oh my god, it's Freddie!
Everybody!
Sheebie, Ola. It's me, Funtime Freddie,
and welcome to Elton...
Trat is going by too fast. I can't read it.
Hold on.
I have to start over.
Sheebie, Ola.
It's me, Funtime Freddie,
and welcome to Elton Ring Special Edition
and Diamond Edition.
Thank you, Freddie.
Somebody said no profile picture?
I want to see what the profile picture is.
Go to channel.
That's pretty sick.
That's pretty gnarly.
I like it.
Sheebie, get up the furry allegations, please.
You know, Toma is trying to teach me
just to embrace being a furry.
I'm still resistant.
But, you know...
Maybe I'll get some,
you know, sweet furry lovers
in my audience.
You know how that can be.
Diamond Edition? Yes, Diamond Edition.
Don't doubt
what Freddie says, bro.
Okay?
Now it'll attack.
Attract.
What is that?
Explain. Just beat Mogue.
Nice job!
Good on you, bro.
Furry Oilers?
There are furry Oilers?
I'm sorry, that's a funny concept to me.
Furries do have a lot of money.
Because I got lots of good art.
My friend paid off her college tuition
with just making very sexy art.
Hola, chica.
Oh, you're weak against this.
You're very weak against this.
Ow.
I see to stay alive.
Oh, I see to stay alive!
Ow.
Oh, I'm so close.
No, no, no, no.
Okay, okay, this is easy.
This is easy, guys.
I can do this one. You guys see how well I dodge.
Aren't you impressed with my dodging ability?
I'm very good at dodger.
Never knew.
Wait, Muppets are considered furries?
All right, guys, I'm a furry.
You hear her first.
Shibi, furry.
Easy clap, easy clap, easy clap, easy clap, bro.
Easy peasy.
I really forgot he was weak to magic shit.
Does any furry want to be my sugar daddy?
I have cat medical bills to pay.
Oh, that would miss him.
I'm trying to keep him, like, here.
Oh, every time I heal,
I literally have to do it in, like, one run.
Why roll into that one?
Come out.
Oh, I just noticed that.
Come on.
Oh, fuck, I was getting too eager.
I thought I was going to kill him.
There we go.
Hand over your fucking sword.
Thank you.
I need that. Appreciate it.
Let's fucking go.
See, when I'm not fucking over-leveled,
I mean, under-leveled,
for like a dude, I can usually get them.
So proud of me. Thank you.
Thank you, guys. I killed something.
I did it.
That's why he wasn't trying to dodge.
Well, him, like, dodging is different.
I don't know if this
scales properly.
I need more strength.
I fucking love this shit.
Oh, it's so fucking sexy.
Oh, fuck it.
Oh, yes, daddy.
Sorry.
All right.
Cool.
Nice.
Noink. Wow.
A whole zero runes.
Thank you, Madika.
I'll be taking this sword.
And I'll be taking- I forget
I don't need to go to a grace to teleport.
I'm such a fucking-
All right, let's see.
If this helps.
Why do you look like a Muppet?
I don't know why the fuck do you look like a Muppet?
Fucking Julio Passos. Fuck you.
Get out of here.
I'm sorry.
I'm over-tired.
I'm raging at a game.
It's not the fucking time.
All right.
Yeah.
Doxic is effort.
Do you have enough strength to wield that even two-handed?
Yeah.
All right.
Because my strength is at like 12
and you need 15.
Oh fuck, it's at 11.
That's fine.
We'll find out.
Let's go.
Can I get a Hoyah?
Yah.
Come on.
No.
Oh fuck, this is worse.
I like this one because you can
jump away.
Oh god, what is this?
I think I need more strength, guys.
I'm stuck.
Oh no.
He's gonna fucking kill me.
No, it needs 15.
Does it?
I don't know. Let's find out.
Well...
Shit.
All right, well...
Let's try this.
Because again, bleeding.
We'll try to get that blade damage.
I'm so determined to fucking
beat this guy.
If you do a heavy attack after a back dodge,
you do a follow-up.
Although it doesn't really matter at this point.
Since I don't have the stats.
We'll just see if we can keep it up with this.
What the fuck was that?
I don't know what happened.
I think you two handed the fang.
I just two handed it and it fucked me up.
I only did 14 damage.
I don't have enough strength, bro.
I don't have enough strength.
My little fucking muppet arms can't lift up
the fucking huge ass thing.
Sorry, I'm cursing a lot.
Okay.
Spits it out.
He's my fucking friend.
You can't dog pile
on the jellyfish. You're cheating.
Take off your hacks.
My neighbors are probably sick of me.
I'm gonna fucking beat your ass.
Beat your ass.
I don't care.
I don't care if I'm in lava. I'm beating your ass.
Anyone with one strike
can keep me in for it.
Must be hard playing with the controller using a muppet.
It is very difficult.
Um.
I realize that I just lost all my runes doing that.
Uh, I don't really know how many runes
I got from that though, so I don't really care.
Um.
I just, I need a good weapon, you know.
Oh
See immediately immediately I can only kick you
Can you like stop you stop dogfiling on the jellyfish, I don't know what is your deal, bro
I'm really gonna fucking kill myself. I'm gonna do it right now. I'm killing myself
And they'll do the force
Wait, do I have the ratting in source ill on
I
Take more damage
No, I fucking love that so much, okay
Let's try it, let's try it
Awkward I definitely take more damage guys. That's for sure. I can assure you that I
Am ripe for the damage
Let me talk. I'm like trying to do shit and you're like
Can't even get close to you because there's lava fucking everywhere
Can you
Can you like stop having a temper tantrum for like just a second so I can like poke you in the ass
How did you already kill him
What
I'm pressing heal
Okay, I'm doing a little bit more damage
I'm gonna search for her
So get shimmy lock in should be easy. Yeah
She's training us out for a big wizard. I'm getting epi, but I want to finish this
Just five hours of me trying to beat a fucking lizard
I
Just need to keep him alive
I might not make it
Keep sick in him
Now damn I am definitely taking it
Okay, okay, we run around run around
Yeah, I didn't make it fuck
It's not fun
It's fine, you got him poison that's all I wanted
Sound like fucking Elmo are you done? Oh my god, I'm running into the lava
Bro, what is
Only human should be allowed to spam attacks not AI this this is ridiculous. I can't even
Oh actually I was better being close up
Sorry, my pinky toe was in a flame of lava
Just couldn't win for hours. Oh man
Hey, I ruined my Elton string stream. Nice title. I'm definitely considering
I'm probably gonna take a nap for a little bit wake up send alarm beat this guy off stream
And then we'll play in the morning
Oh
Well, I'm just gonna stay here until that goes away
I'm kind of terrified. My son just died. I heard his screams of jellyfish terror
That's really too sad
I'm just gonna let him kill me
24 hour elder during stream
What you first tried off stream, I would hate that I was so pissed like nobody fucking saw this
Cuz that's that's literally what happened when I was finding a boss on lines of p. I fought it off stream
And then like it took me three more tries and I got it and I'm like very fucking serious
Fucking clown bitch
Oh
I'm stuck as you can see I'm in like fucking stop lock shit. You got this. Yeah sure
Sure
I'm so late. I'm so
I'm so like
Autismally focused on this now. I'm sorry like I'm just like I need to finish I need to get it done
I need to be to me. I need to be to me. I need it. I need it. I need it
I need it now. I need it now. I can't sleep until I do. I have to I have to I have to I have to be
I have to you
Okay, fly jellyfish fly
Out
Really
Why do I feel like it knocked back harder, it's not even like I get extra damage. I just feel like I get knocked back harder
Oh, we just turned around and killed him
I
Love it when I clip into the thing it's great
Such a strong co-wonka woman, I don't know about that. I
Am definitely doing more damage because he jellyfish to brody it lasts as long
Fuck you
Not doing shit again
Like I could be like making shit I could be doing a bunch of other stuff, but you know, we don't do that out here
Okay, you see he didn't get trapped in the fucking door this time
I was gonna take the heat off of him so he can continue to spam the poison
To get out of this fire to go away, that's fine perfect
I
There's lava here, I can't really do much I don't think you got poison
It's fine
It's literally all dependent on if he gets poisoned I can beat him which sucks
But it's just because I'm underleveled it's a fact
I
Know that worked out
Quickly blood loss, please
Oh fuck am I dead am I dead? No, I'm not dead
Holy shit, holy shit
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god
Oh
It's doing that weird thing where it locks on
And only his head instead of it's happening just what I want
Oh
No, not the brazier
No
I
No, no, no, no, no, please no, oh brother
Think I can do it out jelly. I'm wondering if I should wait till the towards like I get him half done
Feels less than half the damage, okay good to know I wasn't paying attention to my my FP to be honest with you
Okay, we'll try it without jelly and for a little bit
I can get him trapped in a corner when he does that he should be actually
Fine to manage because then he won't be doing so much lava everywhere
This
So you can get a head start
Maybe because in the lava run the heat the automatically the AI aggro's the thing what you've been doing a lava run
Oh
Sorry
Okay, right off the rip. We're just he did not want me touching his booty hole
Okay
Bro, I'm getting my shit kicked in right now
Let's see, let's see if he's okay over here. He doesn't wander into fucking lava like he's doing right now actually
Okay, yeah, uh jellyfish is gonna die
That was fucking waste
Oh brother
Yeah
I know that was a better rate for that one
I
Don't even want the moon veil. I just want to kill him. I just want to kill him
Time is it 11 fuck
Alexander only you would fucking help me
What if I spawn it right on him
I
I'm getting too eager, I'm sorry, I just want to kill him.
This will actually be a good run if I never run.
I should put on some fire-resistant shit, to be honest with you.
Why are you doing this multiple times?
I'm stuck.
I'm already down to the blasts, I just don't know why I'm bothering.
Actually, this is helpful because when I do this, I can immediately actually dodge out of the stuff, and I'm not using it.
This spawn on top of him seems good, it seems like that worked actually.
Okay, let me ask him nicely to die, I'll try that next.
I would appreciate it if you died nicely, calmly, died, that would be really nice.
If you could, that would really be so great, I would really appreciate that.
It would be cool if he didn't kill my friend.
Two, that would be super nice, but I don't know if you can be trusted with that.
I'm stuck, I'm in the swamp, I'm fine.
Ow, that wasn't nice.
Ow.
I don't think it worked.
I've heard a woman ask me to die, I probably won't.
Excuse me, could you please, K-Y-S, kiss your sister, and I just show them a picture of Amy, and then he just licks, I don't think.
I opened you, I'm jumping on you, I'm jumping, ow.
Ow.
That's fine, anyways, okay.
You get him, Jilly, I'm gonna be dead on the other side.
I don't think bosses run out of stamina, but thank you.
Inside of a dragon is kind of hollow, WTF.
Riddle me this, riddle me this, Batman.
If I went to dragon place and got the dragon head that does the blight, do you think that would be effective?
I would, would I need more arcane for that?
I'm not sure.
Kind of wish I had some coffee, because I want to keep playing.
We need arcane, yeah, no shit, rotten breath, yes.
We would need more arcane.
Face in arcane.
See, I'm going to use some jump to essentially move that out of a large way to those attacks.
Now while we're lying, it's going to be a throw-up, which while I do get sloppy, I do hit quite a few times, which I could have otherwise avoided.
It's so impressive.
As I said, the house starts with the jiggy-tarnas here, and my brand-new strategy is to move some relief to the place we can to be guessed at damage-race this boss to his hand.
If I take a massive hit there, the only thing that I'm not going to be using is spirit summons, and that's mainly because they make the boss unpredictable.
I know what the boss is going to do in the kind of room-space for this boss.
Oh, I knew it.
And if I have spirit summons, it's essentially going to pull it to make the boss do something to jump on a low attack.
So I'm not going to be using a low-bottom smash attack, which you can very well use that if I want to.
If I want to.
Just go for standing palestons attacks, standing on low attacks to just build.
And I can say, though, is that you're sure that you don't get yourself too close on a low blow.
This boss loves to do that, working in tight waves.
Use his mag at every map.
Make a move, and she's able to rep the direction.
To realize you're surrounding herself at night.
So this boss loves to do this attack, two, three times a move, and three times a move.
He does it twice, but I don't get kicked in this fight.
Sorry, I'm learning.
I didn't realize he does a lot of jumping.
Like he just jumps to avoid the ground pound.
Okay.
All right, let's try it.
Studying Sun Tzu in some of the Bible.
Studies.
Oh, yeah.
No, I love studying like move sets.
I think scale.
That's I think that's why I like this game a lot because I didn't know I like those things until I played this game.
Okay, we're not.
We're just gonna.
Yeah, whatever.
Fucking hell.
My eye is itchy.
My eyes itchy.
Hold on.
I realize if I stay in one place, he also stays in one place.
He's gonna do it a third time.
Oh, I timed that incorrectly.
It's fine.
Oh, I didn't do that.
So he does a jump when he ground pounds, but I don't know the timing for that yet.
Jesus, please let me get up.
Why am I?
My timing is all fucked up.
I think because I'm too tired.
Since when do you spam this attack?
Hello?
You know what?
I think I'm too tired.
Okay, we're playing tomorrow bright and early.
You better be ready, boys.
I'm gonna take a nap.
I'm gonna wake up.
I'm gonna play some more.
This boss will be dead in God for the time.
And then in the morning, I don't know.
I don't know what's going on.
Just stay in the lookout.
All right.
So I'm gonna say bright and early.
Hey, damn.
No kidding.
I don't know.
I'll be around.
If you guys don't have plans for 4th July or your U.K. or Euro or whatever you are,
we are hanging out or playing some melding ring.
My head hurts.
I need to sleep.
Um, yeah, yeah.
Today's your birthday.
Oh my God.
Happy birthday.
Good for you.
Aren't you happy you're still on this earth?
I'm happy you're still on this earth.
Your town is already celebrating that.
That's, yeah.
I think that's why I swear I thought I heard fireworks.
Oh, it's cool.
I'm going to see.
So they do the fireworks like in my town center and I can see that from my apartment
building.
So it'll be really cool.
I can just look outside and see them.
Yeah, I'm just like very determined when it comes to games.
Like I've had friends sit and watch me play.
Um, and they're just like, why don't you just do this or that or whatever and like
come back to it or whatever.
I'm like, no.
Like I won't lie.
I was definitely that person that determinedly powered through tree sentinel the first time
I played a hundred because I thought I had to beat him.
So I get it.
Um, I'm just, I just like to see things through, you know, gotta hit that brick wall till it
falls over a hundred percent.
I'm bashing my head through that shit.
You have no idea.
Uh, well, I hope you enjoyed.
Um, I know I did.
I love this game.
I kind of just want to stay up.
I don't have to fucking.
I hate.
Well, I love sleeping.
Like I took like a fucking like three hour, four hour nap today.
I don't know how I'm still tired.
My body's just like, stop.
Um, you love watching people play.
I'm gonna watch me do it.
I do.
I hope you guys enjoy my very colorful commentary.
I know for a fact this video will be fucking tomorrow.
Oh, what are you doing?
She's like walking around like she's up to something.
What are you doing, lady?
Sneaky.
Um, but I hope you, I hope you have a good night or a good day or a good evening or morning
or dusk or dawn or afternoon or early afternoon.
I'll be back tomorrow in Muppet form.
Please check out what is high on heart stream.
They are very entertaining.
I do like her.
Um, and please check out.
I love her.
She made me my Muppet self.
You got amazing Muppet madam today.
Look how nice my little Muppet boobies are.
Her stuff is pinned.
Please check out her Twitch.
She is so lovely.
She's so sweet.
One of the comfiest streamers I've ever watched and also a great friend of mine.
She's helped me a lot when I first heard of VTubing.
I look up to her.
She's awesome.
Please check her out.
All right.
I almost, I watched like Markiplier play like Slay the princess the other day and I literally
subconsciously almost went, until the next video.
Bye.
I'm so fucking tired, dude.
Slay the princess is a good game too.
I would love to play Slay the princess on stream.
Um, oh, I'm so tired.
Okay.
Please don't go.
I don't want to go.
You know I don't want to go.
No, I always want to hang out with you guys.
Sheepie Plier?
I'll be sick.
Um, again, uh, thank you so much and don't think I'm not like mad or anything.
If when you help, I appreciate it.
Trust me.
I'm not mad at anybody.
It's all jokes.
I just, I get a little toxic when I play Elden Ring.
It is what it is.
Guys should have seen me play fucking Counter-Strike.
Holy shit, bro.
Oh my God.
Um, start next stream.
My name is Sheepie Conplier.
Hello, my name is Sheepie Conplier.
You love the toxicity?
You like Amy Madame?
It's funny.
I don't think people would like to watch me rage, but people like to watch me rage.
I just, oh, it's so funny.
I need to eat something.
Actually, I'm not really hungry.
I'm still a little nauseous.
I think maybe they'll have some more crackers.
Ever since I, there's like, like the, these weird knockoff, um, cheese crackers, and I
smelled them and they made me nauseous again.
So I kind of don't want to eat.
Uh.
Well, there's the water.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Sheepie Conplier, and today we'll be playing Elden Ring.
Top of the order to you laddies!
I haven't watched Jacksepticeye in the longest time, but he is someone that I should watch
for this because I know he fucking loves FromSoft games.
Welcome back to some more Elden Ring.
I know I need to, I'll just start ripping off other VTubers and YouTubers intros and
outros and just assimilating them into my own.
Oh, hi, Whopper!
I don't know, I can't even do the laddies voice.
Uh, I'm a little tired, guys.
I'm a, I'm a fucking Muppet.
I'm gonna start calling people Muppets.
You're a fucking Muppet.
Fia, are you, what are you doing?
I'm turning EU?
What do you mean?
You fucking Muppet.
I don't say Muppet.
Muppet.
Maybe stalling to talk maybe.
Does any of you guys want to talk me in?
I'm like real tired.
I need to be carried to bed.
Um, I got this like new lingerie set, not like lingerie, it's more like just like
from, um, Savage X Fenty, which is like one of my favorite brands.
It's so comfy, like this is a bra, I feel like I could sleep in.
It's so comfy.
I'm squeezing my own boobies.
Um, and like the underwear is comfy too.
And then I'm wearing a robe.
And that's all I'm wearing.
And then you got my little Muppet body.
Imagine my little Muppet body in lingerie.
How does that make you feel?
I'm tempted to permanently become a Muppet.
I might just tell Strani, just Muppetize me captain, you know?
I'm super soft.
I have like velvety faux rabbit fur.
Nice you mentioned it.
It doesn't, to be honest, it still doesn't fit properly because like I just, I think
I'm just in denial about my cup size.
I've never been over a triple D, but I think I may be bigger than a triple D.
So it is what it is.
It's just really comfy though.
I think it's because it doesn't have a wire in it.
And I'm like, it is nice.
But it doesn't have like, I couldn't wear this with like outside.
It would just suck.
It would just like my boobies would be flopping everywhere.
Just Muppet me the fuck up, bro.
Muppet the fuck up, bro.
Muppet the fuck up.
I think everybody needs to Muppet up.
Is there anything that they know existed?
Again, I just have a giant hole.
So, uh, you with that as you mutt, you wish.
Well, not as you wish as I wish, if anything.
I'm in control here.
Confused, horny.
Feels strange.
Ah!
Are you horny here?
Or do you like some of my Muppety Muppet body here?
I have a big gaping Muppet hole just for you.
Wait, who truly is in control if you're out of Muppet?
Who the fuck is holding?
Do you not see my own hand holding up my Muppet body?
Like you're Jennifer Carly just a Muppet.
Jennifer Carly.
Are you scared?
No, pick your Bible back up.
I want you to stroke your Bible.
Really look at the cover.
Pour over the pages.
And, uh, I should have covered my Muppet body.
I have a big gaping Muppet.
The temptation of the Muppet.
Yes, what did you call it?
Imagine my smooth little Muppet's hands touching your face.
Imagine my smooth little Muppet's mouth.
Isn't it you?
And your lippies?
I guess now is a bad time to say I was working on something.
What are you working on?
You're working on a Muppet for yourself?
Muppet's gonna feel like a starch sock we're working on.
I did say earlier, use me like one of your socks.
Use me like one of your French socks.
Oh, you'll see.
Please make this an ASMR role play.
Are you sure?
You think this stream is getting demonetized?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Like my Muppet-y bobbies.
You like my beauty mark, my Muppet-y boobies.
It's pretty nice.
Oh, you'll see.
I'm scared.
What is she cooking up?
I'm tempted to draw a Muppet smut.
Smut it, if you would.
Somebody turn off my computer for me right now.
It's not the Muppet.
I mean, it is the Internet.
You're right.
Rule 34 exists.
Learn.
Learn?
Lord have mercy.
Jamie, please tell me you heard of the term Muppet-necking.
I don't know what you're talking about.
What is Muppet-necking?
Is it when you like, nosle someone's neck and you're just like...
You know?
How do I save?
System.
Oh, look.
I'm going to quit.
Yes.
Six hours.
Exactly.
Let's go.
Six hours, one second.
Oh, my God.
From software.
I can't be controlling the Muppet, but it's the Muppet control me.
They're just my little puppets on strings.
They're all puppets in my hair room.
They're all Muppets in my hair room.
They're all going to feel like starch socks by morning.
That's all I'm going to say.
Muppet-she-be-muppet-get-me-wrung-burn-a-light.
I've never felt felt like this before, baby Jesus.
I have a hundred percent cashmere.
Yeah, I can step down by my...
I don't have any legs, but...
I have permission to put my hand up.
No, only Peepies.
Peepies on there.
I didn't know I needed that.
I hope you are vigorously stroking yourself right now to my Muppet self.
You better.
It is a challenge.
Can you?
Can you read the Bible to this Muppet boy?
I want you to...
You beat your hand inside and you feel something pulling you in.
It's my Muppet.
Wait, that doesn't work.
Muppet-muppet-tussi?
How do you guys fucking clip in this shit?
Wait, no, don't do it.
My mussy?
My Muppet-tussi?
Yeah.
You're gonna read the Bible to Muppet-chibi?
Yes.
You cannot read the Bible to anything else besides Muppet-chibi.
Muppet-chibi is for God.
Imagine.
He's getting way out of your hand.
Your hand, it's up my ass.
I'm a Muppet.
He has stretched my legies.
He has piggy hooves.
I see why adults call out Muppet-muppet day now.
Shibby please, Shibby please, what?
Yes.
Just place it.
What is your Bible?
It's in my Muppet-y mouth.
I promise you that Muppet-y slubby-tubby.
The Muppet-toppy.
I'm a Muppet.
I don't need fucking stuffing.
Muppets don't have stuff, actually, in my hand.
In my mouth, you can stuff them.
I don't know.
I suppose my Vavity Muppet mouth.
I can't do my Patreon voice.
It has to be a higher pitch in order for me to do that.
My Vavity Muppet mouth.
You want to make me a starch sock by learning?
I think I'll let you touch my Muppet-y buttons if you insist.
Go on.
Touch them.
Cut them in your little hand.
They are soft, are they not?
I'm made from the finest cotton, harem.
The Muppet chest is...
Yes, yes it is.
I am dead as cannon.
If you squeeze it, it makes a little...
Wait.
I was hoping I had a squeaky toy thing, but I don't.
That would have been really comical timing.
Fuck.
My tentacle is just staring me in the face.
I don't have anything within reach that can make a squeaky noise.
Man in a tentacle.
Coming into the...
I'm tired.
Hi, I'm Sheeby Cottonbum, and you're watching VLR Channel.
Bye-bye.
Brain shutting down.
A booba has a squeaker.
I'm gonna squeeze my own booba, actually.
Okay.
This is pay-picking.
What, excuse me?
Muppet furry PNGTuber.
We made a lot of products today.
Anyways, it's been fabulous, everyone.
I hope you enjoy today's Elden Ring Strip,
or I'll see you tomorrow.
At what time?
I don't know.
It'll be a gorilla.
Ooh, ah-ah-ah.
Good night.
And farewell.
I'm gonna muck-wuck-wuck on you.
Muppet fidget-tree?
Thank you, boy, for the T9.
Okay.
I guess I'll go now.
I guess this is where...
I wish I had one of those, like,
comical hooks to pull me slowly to the side.
Excuse you.
Why is it talking about fucking multiplayer anyways?
Exactly, Boomi.
Exactly.
Farewell.
Goodbye.
Now.
Yeah, you still smell pretty stinky.
Even with my muppet nose,
I can tell that you smell like a...
muppet-y...
mupp-puss.
Muppet.